this is jocko podcast number 315 with
echo charles and me jocko willink good
evening echo good evening
seven plus 14 equals a 21 b 22 c 23 d 24
a boy buys a sandwich for 20 cents
milk for 10 cents
and pie for 15 cents
how much does he pay for it all
a 30 cents b 35 cents c 45 cents d 50
cents
a rose is a kind of a animal b
bird c fish d flower
awkward
most nearly means a ignorant b dangerous
c clumsy
d vulgar
irate most nearly means a irresponsible
b insubordinate c
untidy d angry
okay
so those right there
clearly not the most difficult problems
those are examples from a brochure that
was handed out to potential
service recruits in the 1960s to explain
to them the type of questions that they
were going to be asked
on
the afqt the armed forces qualification
test
what we now call the asvab
in order to qualify them for military
service
and i read that from
an appendix that's in a book called
mcnamara's folly
the use of low iq troops in the vietnam
war
and this book was written by a guy by
the name of hamilton gregory
who
served in vietnam himself
and in this book
gregory explains that not everyone could
pass that test
which meant
that
there were people who
did not qualify
to join the service it meant they did
not have the
cognitive capacity to be a soldier
but guess what
in order to fight a war you need men
and mcnamara
devised a way
to get more men
into the military whether they were
capable or not and it is a very sad
story
indeed
you're going to find out that hamilton
gregory
actually ended up
very close with some of these people
during some parts of his
service so let's go to the book in 1966
the u.s war in vietnam was heating up
rapidly
president johnson and his secretary of
defenses robert mcnamara were faced with
a problem the armed forces needed more
troops
for the war zone but there was a
shortage of men who were considered fair
game for the military draft there were
plenty of men of draft age which is 18
to 26 in america but most of them were
unavailable
many were attending college using
student deferments to avoid the draft
others had found safe havens in the
national guard and reserves which by and
large were not sent to vietnam
so if you in the national guard of the
reserves
you weren't going to get sent to war
that's not true anymore
but in vietnam if you were in the
national guard you weren't getting sent
to vietnam still others were
disqualified because they scored poorly
on the military's mental and physical
entrance tests
how could johnson and mcnamara round up
enough men to send a war they realized
they would anger the vote powerful
middle class if they drafted college
boys and if they sent national guardsmen
and reservists to vietnam
so instead they decided to induct the
low-scoring men
whom johnson
referred to in a secret white house tape
as
quote second-class fellows
end quote on october 1st 1966 mcnamara
launched a program called project 100
which lowered the mental standards men
who had been unqualified for military
duty the day before were now deemed
qualified by the end of the war
mcnamara's program had taken 354 000
substandard men into the army marine
corps air force and navy
among the troops these men were often
known as mcnamara's morons or the [__]
core or mcnamara's boys
military leaders from william
westmoreland the commanding general in
vietnam to lieutenants and sergeants to
the platoon level
viewed mcnamara's program as a disaster
because many of the project a hundred
thousand men were slow learners
they had difficulty absorbing necessary
training because many of them were
incompetent in combat
they endangered not only themselves but
their comrades as well
a total of 5
478 low iq men died well in the service
most of them in combat their fatality
rate was three times as high as other
gis
an estimated 20 000 were wounded and
some were permanently disabled
there were also tens of thousands of
other quote second class men who were
not part of project 100 000 but were
inducted despite medical defects such as
missing fingers and blindness in one eye
psychiatric disorders social
maladjustment and criminal backgrounds
military leaders didn't want them but
were forced to accept them
we don't know how many of them died or
were wounded
while i was in the army
which was 1967-1970
i got to know some of mcnamara's
substandard soldiers and i vowed that
someday i would tell their stories and
give the historical background
this book is the fulfillment of that vow
there's the opener that's just the
prologue
it's very disturbing to hear this
and it also you know
as we read through this you're going to
definitely think of forrest gump
you you you've all seen that movie
forrest gump and you think oh how did
that guy how was that guy in the
military he's a perfect example and
you're going to hear plenty of examples
like that same thing with full metal
jacket you know private pile
obviously
a guy you think well how could he
actually get recruited well here's how
mcnamara's 100k
here's a note he says authors note i am
aware words like [__] [__] fatso
and dwarf are considered insensitive and
offensive in today's society but i use
them because they were widely used in
the 1960s and it would mar the
historical accuracy of my report if i
replace them with words that are kinder
likewise i sometimes quote individuals
whose descriptions are harsh and
unsympathetic but i have included them
to document how men who were different
were viewed and treated in those days
names and certain other identifying
features of the men at fort benning have
been changed to protect the privacy of
the individuals and their families so
there's some language clearly that is
considered offensive today and he knows
that but he wanted to kind of give a
feel of what these guys were like and
how they were being treated
what they were being called back in the
day
so moving into this a little bit getting
into how his story started he says one
morning in the summer of 1967 i was
seated with over a hundred men in a room
at the armed forces induction center in
nashville tennessee at it was the height
of the vietnam war and i had volunteered
for service in the u.s army
sergeant walked into the room and
announced that all of us would begin
which would leave soon for travel to
fort benning georgia to begin our army
training then he asked does anyone hear
a college graduate
i raised my hand and he motioned me to
follow him
he took me down a hallway to a bench
where a young man was sitting he
informed me that the young man was named
johnny gupton
who is also being assigned to fort
benning i want you to take charge of
guptan he said go with him every step of
the way
without bothering to lower his voice he
explained that guptin could neither read
nor write and would be neat and would
need help filling out paperwork when we
arrived at benning
then he added make sure he doesn't get
lost
he's one of mcnamara's morons
i had never heard the term and i was
surprised that the sergeant would openly
insult guptan
in a few weeks i would learn that
mcnamara's morons was a team that many
was a term that many officers and ncos
used to refer to low iq men who were
taking in taken in the military under a
program devised by defense secretary
robert s mcnamara to raise their iqs
and mold them into productive soldiers
he goes on a little bit further and says
i was nervous about the rigors ahead but
i felt brave and stoic and important i
envisioned losing weight and bulking up
my muscles and becoming a lean green
fighting machine as the popular saying
had it i looked beyond the eight weeks
of hell and pictured myself going home
on leave looking hard and fit
i tried to make
small talk with gupton
but he didn't say much i asked him what
state he was from
but he didn't know
he spoke with a hillbilly accent
and used mountain phrases like i knowed
it and sodi water
he looked unhealthily thin
i was surprised that he knew nothing
about the situation he was in he didn't
understand what basic training was all
about and he didn't know that america
was in a war
i tried to explain what was happening
but at the end i could tell he was still
in a fog
so that's
that's that's what we're um dealing with
here you know guys that
don't even know what state they're from
and there's a bunch of details in here
you got to get the book and read it um
just as he interacts with some of these
folks
you know they have to put down their
address they don't know what their
address is they can't write
they can't fill out a form because they
can't read it's
it's very very sad
when is this book written
he wrote it um i mean he wrote it now
but it's taken place in 1960
whatever but this book came copyright
2015. oh yeah yeah okay
and i actually researched to try and get
in touch with hamilton gregory but
unfortunately
he passed away
here's an example of what we're dealing
with guptan's new combat boots provided
a challenge he could tie the laces but
the knot was primitive and ineffective i
tried to teach him how to make a
standard knot to no avail so i ended up
tying his boots every morning
he says guptan was unable to make his
bunk to strict army specifications so
floellen was another guy flewellen and i
had to do a job for him every morning
guptan had difficulty distinguishing
between officers and sergeants he goes
through all kinds of examples of
what's going on in in boot camp and and
they show up at boot camp and
they're doing standard boot camp stuff
you know i want to go to vietnam i want
to kill some viet cong um don't call me
sir i work for a living kind of all
those stereotypical things that that you
hear about all that's going on
fast forward a little bit
this chapter is called weaklings
fatties and dummies one morning as the
185 trainees of bravo company were
assembled in front of captain bosch he
called out the names of 15 men including
me and guptan
we were ordered to come forth and stand
in line in front of the captain he
announced that we had been identified as
being deficient you're the scum of this
company a goddamn bunch of weaklings and
fatties and dummies he said
from now on we would be known as the
muck squad you know what muck is that's
a [__] at the bottom of a sewage pit
that's what you are worthless [__] i'm
gonna run your asses all day long he
said that bravo company had a good
chance of compiling the highest average
on the final pt test of any company at
fort benning but that we threatened to
drag down the company average we were
still members of our original platoons
but whenever captain bosch asked for the
muck squad we had to leave our comrades
and line up in front of him we received
physical training beyond what we
received with our platoons it was often
given before lunch and after dinner so
you can kind of pick this up and i
forget if i highlight this or not but
but the guy actually hamilton gregory is
not in good shape
and so he shows up and he mentions you
know i want to lose some fat and build
some muscle so he's not like an athletic
guy that shows up and and apparently
that's why he's getting called out
here's another interesting story about
what we're dealing with
someone in the barracks discovered that
guptin thought a nickel was more
valuable than dime because it was bigger
in size i saw him being cheated by a
trainee who said i'll give you this big
nickel if you give me your little dime
uh he says word of gob guptan's
ignorance about coins apparently spread
to the officers because one day muk
squad lined up
captain bosch appeared with several
visiting officers and the first thing
they did was show gupta and a nickel and
a dime and asked him which he would
prefer they all grinned when he pointed
to the nickel
did you ever think that do you ever
remember thinking that that a nickel was
worth more than yeah when i was five
yeah me too i remember that because
it kind of made sense in a way before
you're good or you you knew basic math
yeah because look you got a penny which
kind of segregates itself because it's
not made out of the shiny silver stuff
or whatever it's made out of something
you know more brown but
i actually can remember thinking a penny
was more valuable than a dime oh okay i
was just going sized yeah yes it's going
we're just going mass but it makes sense
if you just exclude the dime uh nickel
relationship and the penny two there's
other facts but if you exclude that
little relationship it makes sense
because you go up you go quarters bigger
then you got the 50 cent piece that's
even bigger and you got the dollar
that's even bigger back cool but the
point is what age did you figure out
that that wasn't the deal i know bro but
i just said i can kind of relate a
little bit you can relate to guptan when
you were five because this guy's in the
military which paints a picture actively
trading
coins yeah that's true it's awful yeah
um
he says then the visitors stood in front
of one man at a time and asked such
questions as who's the president united
states
this question was one of the most most
the men could not answer
one of the officers looked at me
probably noting my goofy face and asked
where are we fighting a war vietnam sir
where's vietnam located i replied as
much
as i could muster
sir vietnam is situated in asia directly
south of china and adjacent to laos and
cambodia he looked surprised by my
intelligent response
and his fellow officers grinned he's a
college graduate interjected copter
bosch but he's badly out of shape
one of the visitors who is a captain
asked gupton which rank is higher
captain or a general
guptin was speechless for a few moments
and then stammered i don't know drill
sergeant drill sergeant the officer
yelled he pointed at his insignia and
said don't you know these two bars mean
captain
don't you know what you're supposed to
say sir
captain bosch said can you believe this
idiot was drafted i'll tell you who else
is an idiot [__] robert mcnamara how
can he expect us to win a war if we
draft draft these morons
captain bosch's contemptuous remark
about defense secretary mcnamara was
typical of the comments i often heard
from
career army men who detested mcnamara's
lowering of enlistment standards in
order to bring low iq men into the ranks
so we always well no we always this is
something that comes up all the time
today too right we're always concerned
about lowering the standards of things
because when you start to lower the
standard standards are there for a
reason
we start to lower the standards
and we don't know what's going to happen
i think that's the scariest thing about
lowering standards is that you
you don't know you don't know what's
gonna happen
you just know what has worked
and even when things you say they quote
worked you know that those things have
been stressed and sometimes they didn't
work all that well and maybe the
standards should have been higher so now
we're going to lower them
yeah but concerning thing to do a lot of
times or
a lot of times i don't even know what
that means but the
the thought behind it is lowering
standards because we need more people
well that's what's happening right here
right so it's like a it's like a this
constant balancing act because sure you
can have more people but you can't lower
the standards all the way down so that
more people actually hurts because
they're a bunch of people who are
incapable or whatever that's the that's
the point yeah so
i see the unders like because what if
your standards are too high kind of like
no one can meet these standards so now
you got one guy here or three guys and
they can't do the job because there's
only three of them
so let's get some you know some other
guys doing some other stuff we're sure
that you know one of these three guys
could probably do the job
of eight of these other guys but they're
over here doing uh you know busy doing
other stuff so let's get eight more guys
you know but when they start to get in
each other's way
yeah and then we gotta well i guess the
question is really
where do you draw the line yeah and
that's what's hard to figure out yes sir
because
well
like i said you have your standards and
you think well we kind of have survived
with these standards
for
four wars
right they kind of worked and all of a
sudden we're going well you know what
we're actually going to lower these
standards
that's a rough move to make
yeah
especially and this is very common for
mcnamara
to just make decisions and impose things
without
consulting the front-line troops that
actually have to train and then go fight
alongside
these
people that are not capable
a little bit more about boot camp here
they began at 4 30 day was filled with
exercise instruction menial chores all
accompanied by incessant shouting and
insults we were called a variety of
disparaging names including [__]
[__] [__] scumbags slimeballs
pansies and queers
one verbally clever sergeant would refer
to a poorly performing trainee as a sad
sack of [__] or an idiotic turd
or he would tell him that whale [__] at
the bottom is at the bottom of the ocean
and you're lower than whale [__]
at night we got little sleep
we were supposed to go to bed at 10
o'clock but as things turned out we were
up until 12 30 which meant we only got
four hours of sleep
some nights we didn't even get four
hours of sleep if we had to pull fire
guard duty we'd spend an hour patrolling
inside and outside the barracks watching
for fire then we would wake up our
replacement
there's a bunch of
interesting information about boot camp
and then he says i learned that captain
bosch wanted to rid as many of us
members of the muck squad as possible
because they threatened to pull down the
company average for the end of basic
training tests which is this is pretty
typical of the military where
there's some weird
rule or some weird goal that causes all
these unintended circumstances like okay
we're going to judge you we'll give a
company award for the best pt scores and
then people start running people out of
the company and not training that's
unintended consequences in the military
is always i always got to chuckle out of
them
but it happens in every industry so
that's why you got to be aware of them
so here's this guy you know the
commanding general or whoever the
the regimental commander probably
thought you know what i want to see i
want to i want to really have something
to strive for let's give let's give the
best companies pt scores a
an award we'll give them a streamer on
their flag yeah that'll be great
so now he just got these these leaders
just getting rid of people
so that's what happens here's a little
bit more
scariness
for a week or so a sergeant was assigned
to accompany guptan at the rifle range i
overheard the sergeant telling other
sergeants that guptan should absolutely
never be allowed to handle loaded
weapons on his own all the sergeants
agreed that big trouble would happen in
the weeks ahead when we trainees
simulated combat with such maneuvers as
fire and movement
in which you advance in parallel lines
with a partner through an assault course
while your partner ran ahead you
provided cover fire then he dropped to
the ground and provided cover fire for
you as you ran ahead and so on down the
field
the sergeants foresaw disaster so this
guy's not even be able to be capable of
the
fundamental rudimentary
tactic of war which is cover move
here
this is where you can see that that
gregory's having some issues
on one of these forced marches he's
getting called a god damn [__] get back
up and run like a man
this continues on after we marched an
hour or so
i got heat cramps in my shoulders and
became dizzy and nauseated at one rest
stop i took a swig of water from my
canteen which made me vomit
flewelin which again is one of his
buddies came over and felt my forehead
which he said was burning up he summoned
sergeant boone who splashed cool water
on my face then to light my load the
sergeant carried my rifle while floellen
carried my pack and we continued our
march when we arrived at the rifle range
i felt sick and dizzy and had
and i was parched
and i walked to a patch of glass lay
down and blanked out next thing i knew i
was in an ambulance headed toward the
hospital medic was taking my temperature
which was 105 when we got to the
hospital my temperature was still 105 i
was stripped down and dunked into a big
hospital tub filled with ice and water i
was kept in the hospital for a few days
and then released back to bravo company
but while i was gone captain bosch
had secured permission
to have me sent to special training
company because i had missed key days of
training and needed quote rehabilitation
for being recycled to another basic
training company
so he's got the opportunity to get rid
of this guy that's slow and not the best
of shape and he gets put in this special
training company
so let's fast forward a little bit to
this special training company when i
arrived at special training company i
was taken
to the orderly room to be interviewed by
the first sergeant undoubtedly
influenced by my goofy face
he said we got to fill out some
paperwork can you read and write
gregory replies i hope so i said i'm a
college graduate he gave me a surprise
look he was just one of the many who
prejudged me because i appeared to be
adult
i smiled and said i bet you i thought i
bet you thought i was one of mcnamara's
morons he grinned and said we got a lot
of morons here we don't need any more
when i told him i wanted to pass through
special training and finish basic as
quickly as possible he seemed pleased
and we ended up having a friendly
conversation there were about 100 men in
special training most of whom had failed
basic training because they possessed
one or more of these attributes mentally
slow weak inept overweight or
psychologically troubled
also present were trainees who were
convalescing from injuries
whereas physical training occupied about
40 percent of our actives in basic
training it consumed 90 percent in
special
training company
we were supposed to get instruction that
would help us with the rifle and test
and the g3 proficiency test but there
was very little assistance
low iq men
were supposed to get remedial reading
lessons but i saw no evidence of such
training at special training it was pt
all day every day
after i stowed my gear in a wall locker
i joined the company which was on the pt
field struggling with the most
excruciating physical torment i have
ever endured in my life
intensive log drills
and he goes on to talk about log pt he
actually has a picture of
of seals in here doing log pt because if
you don't know that's a huge part of not
a huge part it's a
substantial part of basic seal training
we call it log pt yeah it
is that
the log pt is that
mainly
because they're not really exercises
right they're just like oh we want to
introduce this log to your whole thing
to make everything hard or is it actual
like a program
to work out it's well
what he says here is the drill is
nothing but torture involving no true
rehabilitation or strength that's what
he says so maybe that answers your
question
but
um
when you do it in buds you're it's it's
definitely like uh
it's teamwork and strength so you have a
log it's basically a small telephone
pole maybe it's
probably 15 feet long or something like
that maybe maybe you know maybe 10 feet
long do you ever take it in the water oh
yeah does it float you take it in the
water you take it through the obstacle
course like how does it is because water
is not a huge part of it okay and it
would have to flow like otherwise you
would drown right but you know how
there's different okay so on kauai we'd
have logs too we'd mess with or whatever
in the water but
sometimes if they're super dry they'll
float float they're like a little
floatation but if they're not they'll
kind of float but if you get on it it'll
sink and it's a pain in there it's much
more a land device
it's more full yeah but you do
like you you you all put it on your left
shoulder then you do squats then you do
overhead press and you hold it up there
and then you do like left shoulder right
overhead press
and then you do lay down you do sit ups
with it you do you so you just any kind
of
pt calisthenics okay so there's a little
bit of a program there like where it's
like okay like yeah like you do push-ups
you lay down you do like but bench press
with it yeah you know then you do
push-ups on it and then you do sit i
remember doing sit-ups because i
remember they said sit-ups and i was
kind of thinking how how are you gonna
do a sit-up log but yeah you just all
lay there put it across your chest and
do sit-ups with it across your chest
with it across your chest oh so it's
like a little piece of workout equipment
it's a little it's a big piece of
workout equipment
so do you ever and i thought it was you
who might even have said this but i
don't know clarified said so have you
ever do they ever um say
hey just bring this log you guys you
know like to if you're going to the i
don't know what are you calling the
cafeteria no you would meet for log pt
okay so it was pretty specific and then
one for a while they had a log that was
called old misery
that was that sounds fantastic way
thicker yeah
than
the other logs and so if your boat crew
was doing bad they'd give you old misery
and i guess now they have an even better
log which is it's a log but it's cut up
into pieces and tied together with a
rope oh yeah so each piece so they can
tell who's
putting out and who's not so you just
you know you've got your
50-pound chunk or whatever
you know if there's if it's one
continuous log
and i'm under it you're under it and
there's five other people under it it's
kind of hard to tell who's putting out
and who's not yeah they get that log
that's
yeah you're in the middle you're kind of
cruising right you can't be you could be
you probably could be
so now they have this log that's cut up
yeah
and yet attached so let's see how you're
looking now with that part of your log
is sagging
doesn't that psychologically
then again it might do the opposite
because psychologically like if it's all
one log and you kind of can't tell who's
putting out and who's not doesn't that
kind of add to the team building
experience where you kind of gotta trust
the guy yes but let's say i i they
didn't have that log they didn't have
either one of those logs when i went
through we didn't have old misery log
and we didn't have this cut up log
so i don't know
but
you feel you know you should feel peer
pressure to like lift but let's say you
were an instructor yeah and you're
watching this boat crew kind of [__]
kind of fail
and you're wondering hey
who in this boat crew is actually
getting after it right and who's not
yeah hey go grab this cut-up log you
know we're gonna see we're gonna find
out real quick
yeah that's the thing man that that
training makes you it figures out
what your weaknesses are
that's interesting because that really
illustrates the two separate elements of
buds and training and stuff where it's
like the instructor's perspective and
then the the
the user the person right the candidate
what do you call the cadet
the tadpole sure
that's legitimately they call them
tadpoles like a baby frog so it really
clarifies that those the difference in
perspective because look if i'm a little
guy who's not very strong and i and each
one of our and i'm and we've got the cut
up log and everybody and you know you
got i don't know how many guys are in it
but you're in a boat crew with other
guys that are your same height or very
similar
a couple inches difference okay so let's
say my strength
isn't strength it's this running or
something like this yeah but now
the functionality as a team kind of
breaks down a little bit a little bit
from the user perspective here's the
deal if you're my swim buddy you're in
my boat crew we're together and i know
you're a fast runner
and i know that you're not that as
strong as you could be but you're a good
guy guess what come on man we got this
yeah what if you're a turd
and i'm like hey dude you aren't putting
out right so it does help develop
it helps identify
people that do that aren't good
teammates yeah because if you're a fast
runner you might be like hey jocko you
know let's say i'm a slow runner i'm
stronger than you but you're faster than
me yeah hey jocko i'll pace you on this
run
and you help me you push me and
that's the thing you're gonna have good
days and bad day good days and bad days
a you're also gonna have strengths and
weaknesses everyone is yeah so there's
no one
i'm trying to think
there's just about no one that goes
through buds that just
doesn't have any issues yeah they're
going to find because hey you might be a
really fast runner but you get cold
[Music]
you know you might be really good at the
obstacle course
but
you get cold you might be a really good
swimmer but you get cold you see what
i'm saying they're going to find
something and the cold thing is funny
because but i think that's what makes a
lot of people quit is just being cold
and uncomfortable and miserable
yeah and that warmth scene yeah that
warmth but it's so temporary it's this
freaking lie yeah yeah i can i can i
understand but there's very few people
that don't have a problem with some area
of buds
you know what maybe that's strong
there's there's a there's a decent
amount of people that have that are like
oh i was kind of okay at everything yeah
okay believe me i'm not trying to say i
was good i definitely wasn't great at
anything i definitely wasn't but i was
kind of okay and there was people that
were
more okay than me at everything so
there's people that kind of
but if you're really good here's the
here's i guess where it comes in if
you're really good at one thing
chances are
you're not gonna be really good at
everything there were some guys in my
class that were really good at just
about everything they might have one or
two things that they weren't great at
but they were usually pretty small i
mean my honor man a guy named keith
kamir he was pretty much good at
everything he was a stud in the water he
was fast he was awesome at the of course
but i will say this
even the like the guys that were really
good at everything they would very they
actually wouldn't be they wouldn't be
the best at something yeah
they wouldn't be like oh this guy was
gonna win the runs by a record number or
this guy's going to
do the o course in a record number there
might be a guy that's just hey i swam in
college and that guy's just going to
crush the swims yeah yeah
you know we're looking for him on the
run so you smell the
but that's kind of what i'm saying with
the cut up log versus the full log so
it's like hey you're a good teammate you
want to pick up the slack for this guy
and he's going to be you can't pick it's
harder to pick up the slack
definitely harder what i'm saying so
look this poor guy who's great at
swimming great at running and then but
he's just a little skinnier or whatever
you tell people
any if you got a full log a connected
log
it's like hey let's all do this together
i got you hey i'm going to trust you to
put out what you can and that would be
the standard occasionally
this is what would i imagine trigger
this because again they didn't have this
kind of log when i went through what i
think would trigger this is you see a
boat that's now yelling at each other
now we got now we got a problem let's
see what's going on for real yeah
because a lot of times not a lot of
times
it can definitely happen that the guy
that's yelling at everybody is the guy
that's not putting out yeah
yeah
so yeah
but doesn't that kind of work both ways
though
so like
yeah if you got what if i'm weak in the
cut up log
and i man i just can't do these reps the
way the these other guys can
but
if you're a good teammate versus a bad
teammate that's going to show
regardless right be if you're a bad
teammate put it this way because you see
a guy and he's like he's pointing out as
much as he can he's physically weaker
than everybody and i start yelling at
him that's bad yeah unless you're
encouraging him here's the thing i think
that people get get get what's it jammed
up
jammed up during seal training
is
okay and the instructors know this like
let's say you and i are
in a boat crew right and we probably
would have been in bulk because you're 5
11 i'm 5 11 right so we're in a boat
crew
and you're sick
or
you
have cramps or
you maybe you're just not strong
at you know maybe your neck is hurt yeah
yeah and so we're getting told to do
something
and you can't do it
and you're like i can't hold this boat
on my head right now
i can't do this anymore right the
instructors see that and they go over
and they go oh you know what they start
saying to you you're holding back the
team
you're holding back the team yeah the
team doesn't want you you're going to
make them lose when they lose they're
going to get hammered by us we're going
to crush them it's all going to be your
fault they're getting in that person's
head and it works and that person goes
i quit i don't want to be a detriment to
the team right so they quit
it's a lie
it's actually a lie
because everyone every one of those guys
and buds is going to have a time where
they're like oh this isn't my strength
right now and i need can somebody help
me with whatever maybe they got like
heinous there's just things are going to
happen
and well to to a lot of people to a lot
of people things are gonna happen where
they're feeling like oh my god
um
i'm trying to think i don't think i
actually was ever in that bad of a
situation during buds where i was like
gotta carry me across the line or
whatever but i saw it happen to people
yeah and sometimes they would get in
those and it was okay yeah you know hey
man don't worry we got you hey just hang
on we'll
we'll all like someone's freezing i'll
cuddle around them to like
to like get them warm stuff like that
you know that's what you're trying to do
now if the person's a piece of [__]
you're kind of like dude you look a
little chilly over there
so there's like a little selection going
on yeah there's a little class selection
even though it's not formal like in
ranger school they do peer
peer evaluations where you have to rank
everyone in the class and like the last
person is getting dropped if they got a
couple times in right i forget the
actual rules because i never went
through ranger school but yeah but if
you if they rank echo charles number 48
again bottom of the list oh there's
equity charles again we're getting rid
of them
and so they actually rotate through them
like okay rank me last this time rank
echo last next time and so if you do it
smart if you work together no one gets
dropped no one gets peered
out in seal training they
they don't really have that except for
what i'm just talking about which is
looking at a guy going
oh we don't want to help him right now
yeah in his moment of weakness it's
handled internally it's handled
internally
uh all right here we go
let's get back to the book speaking of
this there's various tests he talks
about these this this test that they
have to pass that has
that has a bunch of different components
it's got like a low crawl that you got
to make you got to do these monkey bars
you got to do this
this sprint jump over trenches type
thing there's a grenade throw they got
and then a mile run so that they have a
test that they have to pass
to get out of this
training company
and he and he talks about the various
things and what would make people fail
but one of the things he said is he says
to succeed in the mile run you obviously
needed endurance but you also needed
problem solving ability
at the beginning some of the men would
sprint as if they were running a hundred
yard dash this caused them to become out
of breath and tired they would slow down
and struggle for the rest of the mile
they couldn't grasp or apply what the
sergeants told them about the need to
maintain a steady pace throughout the
entire mile
for most of the men in special training
company passing the test was impossible
their low mental capacity doomed them to
failure they could never pass
under military rules they were supposed
to stay at special training until they
passed all requirements
for for graduation from basic
so what was going to happen to them
would the army keep them in the company
until their service time came to an end
or would they be discharged and sent
home or horrible to imagine would there
be cheating of the kind that captain
bosch had used in bravo company to send
them on to vietnam
so you got this special training company
in order to get out of there you got to
pass the basic requirements to get out
of basic training and then you can go
back to your company and complete
and we already got an example of cap and
boss i was like oh we're going to get
rid of some of these guys
and there's another incident that he
talked about where there's various forms
of cheating that they did
to get someone a better pt score get
someone to pass a test so that's
happening again it's a unintended
consequence of what of this whole
training program
he says here while most of the men did
poorly on the pt test because they were
limited mentally this was not the case
with charles lassner who is very
intelligent but too weak and clumsy to
pass he was about six one had long
spindly legs and he was unable to jump
across the ditch in the run and dodge
and jump
when he ran through the course he took
short dainty steps and he was too
uncoordinated to make the leap
there was something about lasseter that
elicited fierce hatred from the
sergeants they hounded him constantly
calling him a queer and a pansy during
the training day he was screamed at more
than anyone else and in the evenings he
was always given log drills as
punishment finally he couldn't take it
anymore at lunch time one day he sat on
his bunk and declined to fall out for
afternoon formation i tried to coax him
into getting up but he said i can't take
any more of this [__]
he seemed deeply depressed
a sergeant appeared and ordered him to
join the company but he refused the
sergeant fetched the company commander
captain brown who gave him a direct
order to get off the bunk and join the
company on the pt field
again laster refused the mps were
summoned and they arrested him and took
him to the stockade we never saw him
again
i later heard that he was
court-martialed and sentenced to four
years hard labor in the military prison
at fort leavenworth kansas
lasseter's refusal to train must have
caught the attention of high-ranking
officers at fort benning because a few
days after the event a full bird colonel
visited the company
captain brown assembled us in front of
the colonel and said that we were
fortunate to have him with us because he
was a combat veteran of world war ii and
he had important things to say to us
the colonel proceeded to give us a
motivational talk he was a white-haired
distinguished looking officer and he
seemed sincere and concerned without
making any reference to laster's deed he
exhorted us to fulfill our duties and
fight to guarantee the liberties enjoyed
by our families and friends
our nation was involved in a conflict
between the forces of freedom and the
forces of darkness
insidious totalitarian communists wanted
to enslave us and trample upon our
rights
we must be strong men obedient men and
we we must be willing to sacrifice like
washington's troops did at valley forge
in the darkest days of the revolutionary
war or like eisenhower troops did on the
beaches of normandy
he continued in this vein and as he
spoke i glanced at the men near me
they were looking at the speaker
respectfully
but i knew that most of them were not
comprehending his concepts it was a bit
comical as well as a bit sad here was a
well-meaning world war ii veteran who
seemed unaware of the intelligence level
of most of his listeners talking about
patriotism and other abstractions to men
who had no idea of what he was talking
about
yeah
i
i probably should have covered there's
just so many incidents that he covers in
here that kind of identifies the
mental capacity of the people that or
he's dealing with and that's one example
but there's really other obvious ones
you know he talked about not being able
to tie the shoe not be able to read and
write these guys are
they're just they just don't have
the cognitive capacity to to do this
stuff
and that was sort of the
the crux of it um this this world war ii
veteran coming down and delivering this
eloquent speech that the guys just don't
they just don't understand it just
doesn't mean anything to them
fast forward a little bit he says after
a few weeks of special training i took
the final pt test and passed it easily i
was recycled to a new company where i
picked off where i picked up where i
left off with bravo company i finished
basic training with my new company and
then i went to us army intelligence
school
while i was there i happened to run into
a man who had been in special training
as a convalescent while he recuperated
from a hand
injury he informed me that all of the
men i had known at special training had
been quote administratively passed end
quote and sent on to advanced training
he said that the company commander had
been ordered to certify that the men
were malingerers
who could have passed the final test if
they had truly wanted to
just to give you a little bit more of
his story he says after intelligence
school i went to vietnam but i had no
contact with project 100 000 men because
i served as an army intelligence agent
wearing civilian clothes and using a
fake name i posed as a journalist and
worked on a team and that recruited and
trained agents for espionage missions in
cambodia a country from which communist
forces launched attacks on american
forces while i was in vietnam i
continued to write letters to members of
congress
and i had one moment of success and he
he started writing letters to congress
saying hey these guys do not should not
be in the military and they definitely
shouldn't be sent to combat
he says an aide to robert senator robert
kennedy wrote me that he was moved by my
descriptions of the low iq men was
urging the senate to hold a hearing on
project 100 000
i eagerly watched the mail for a letter
detailing plans by senator kennedy
but one morning in june 1968 i heard
news that kennedy had been assassinated
i suspect that my only chance for
congressional action had died with the
senator i was correct
a few years after the war ended i
arranged to get a computer printout
listing all the names of americans who
died in vietnam i skimmed the list
looking for the last names that matched
the names of men i had known at fort
benning
unfortunately the death list included
the names of two men i had known at
special training company ernesto lozano
and freddie hensley lozano was a man i
didn't know very well the only thing i
remembered about him was that some of
the sergeants had given him the nickname
ritardo
freddie hensley of course i knew well i
was not surprised to discover that he
had been killed in combat with his good
looks he probably is was assumed to be
normal
and moved along to vietnam and sent out
in the field and i didn't cover that
part but freddie hensey was a guy that
looked very like a handsome guy normal
looking guy
and but he was just he just wasn't very
intellectually capable
he says freddie's death hit me hard i
remembered how he was always signed an
indication of the tremendous anxiety he
experienced in special training i
remembered how he lacked the mental
quickness to qualify with the m14 rifle
i felt enormous anger
which i feel still feel decades later he
never should have been drafted he never
should have been administratively passed
at special training he never should have
been sent into combat
grasping at straws i got to thinking
that maybe there was another man named
freddie hensley who died so i tried to
find his family by telephoning people in
his hometown with the last name the same
last name i eventually made contact with
his mother
and ascertained that freddie the freddie
i had known was indeed the man who had
died in vietnam
i told her that i had been freddie's
friend at fort benning
she said that she
and the family were proud that freddie
had given his life to defend his country
as we talked i carefully introduced my
belief that freddy should not have been
sent into combat
before long she was expressing grief and
anger and bewilderment
she told me that when freddie received
his draft notice
she and other family members went to the
induction center and explained that
freddy had been a emr
educable mentally [__] classes at
school
and had not been able to drive a car and
that it was a mistake to draft him
in response a drill sergeant reassured
the family that freddie would not be put
into danger he would just do menial jobs
such as sweeping floors and peeling
potatoes
he was a good boy she said
when he was little we used to go
everywhere together he was my little man
she began to sob and she lamented
why did they have to draft him
i want to know why
so now we get into the part of the book
that answers that question why why was
this happening this section's about
project a hundred thousand
um and get some really interesting
information
and you know i usually when we have
vietnam guys on here i always kind of
probe this area
of what was it like what was what was
the protest like you know i kind of and
i've never had anybody
talk too deeply about hey this was this
dynamic environment this polarized they
don't really it seems like because
uh there wasn't social media because
there wasn't 24-hour news cycle if you
lived in
you know ohio and you were going to join
the army
you only saw the other people in ohio
and probably the people that you hung
out with were like yeah well you know
you can join the army you're from ohio
and we're american so we're joining the
army or oh you got drafted cool it was
like it seems like there was less
connection
but it's interesting to hear some of
these statistics that he talks about
here and the way this all looked and the
way this all washed out and the other
thing is we have guys that
either got drafted and said roger that
or they joined up
either way
so
here we go yes the majority of americans
who served in vietnam were technically
volunteers
some were indeed true volunteers such as
the idealistic patriotic youths
described
but most of them volunteered only
because of the way the draft was carried
out local draft boards or military
recruiters told them that they were
likely to be drafted soon and they had
two choices they could submit to the
draft and serve two years probably in
combat
or they could volunteer and serve three
years in non-combat mos which is a
military occupational specialty like
mechanic
cook or computer programmer most men
chose the second say for option because
the vast majority of them would never
have enlisted if the draft had not been
in place
but in place it would be more accurate
to call them draft induced volunteers
and he says i was in another category
which i call draft influenced volunteer
my local draft board put me on a list of
possible draftees but my family doctor
told me without any prompting on my part
that i could that i could avoid the
draft if he wrote a letter to the draft
board about a pre-existing medical
condition
hyperthyroidism i declined his office
offer because the draft board's interest
in me woke out of my
woke me out of my adolescent days and
forced me to take a hard look at the
issues
because i was a strong believer in
america's fight against communism i
decided that it was my patriotic duty to
serve so i signed up for three years in
the army with a promise of an
interesting assignment
military intelligence but i make no
claim to be a hero i did not volunteer
for infantry
so there's
got people getting drafted you got
people getting told hey you're gonna get
drafted bro you might just so they never
would have enlisted voluntarily it's
like saying oh yeah he volunteered
hey echo you can either volunteer or you
can possibly take this job over here
which is gonna get you into combat and
if you don't wanna go to combat
well you're gonna you're gonna sign up
so it's draft induced draft influenced
some different things that happen
just to run some numbers here he says
during the major years of the vietnam
era 1964 to 1973 there were 26 million
800 000 draft age american males
of whom never had to serve in the
military
they were excused because they were
students or fathers or had physical
limitations of some or some other
disqualifying status you know this whole
freaking thing
i used to wonder
i mean when i was younger
well why is going to college how how
does that get you out of military
service you know i i don't get that
right how does that work
wait you're going to call college and
now you can't go fight why can't you
fight
and then it doesn't take much thinking
to realize oh because i'm i my parents
have money they send me to college now i
have to have to go fight yeah and you
mentioned it earlier too right where
where
that'll
kind of make the general society un
unhappy where it's like hey these are
like
they have important roles in our society
because they're educated and all this
stuff
yeah so if you send them to war we don't
have these people yeah there's also the
middle class so the middle class kids
are going to college so if you don't
want to piss off the middle class
parents who are the ones that vote what
do you do you say hey don't worry don't
worry about johnny as long as he's going
to college he doesn't have to worry
about signing up for the draft right
i would imagine back then there's a lot
less people going to college as well
yeah i would imagine until the vietnam
war kicked off and they found out they
could get out of the draft and they were
outlining it
he said that left 32
to fill the ranks
some signed up for hazardous duty but
the majority managed to steer clear of
the battlefield by going to the national
guard or reserves which in the vietnam
war were rarely used for combat or by
signing up for non-combat positions in
the army air force navy or coast guard
some men spent their entire service in
their entire service time in non-lethal
locales such as the us germany korea and
the panama canal zone
so you could have enlisted and gotten
any any of these non-combat jobs
ultimately
out of every 100 american males of draft
age in the vietnam area era only 12 were
sent to vietnam
of these 12 men
nine had non-combat support roles but
weren't entirely risk-free they were
potential targets of rocket uh booby
traps terrorist attacks mortars
the remaining three men
so out of a hundred we're down to three
the remaining three men served under
fire in one of the following high risk
situations
fighting in one of the hardcore combat
arms of the army or marine corps
infantry artillery army special
operations close air support
to serving in the dangerous position
such in the air force navy or coast
guard such as combat aviators or patrol
boat warriors or three
trying to save lives in one of the most
vulnerable of all battlefield jobs
combat medic
while few a few men were eager for
combat most were not tony zinnie a
vietnam veteran who later became a
four-star general the marine corps said
it was hard to find americans who'd
actually chosen to fight in vietnam most
who served there had to be forced to go
so that's what we're dealing with
28 million 26 million people that are
draft 26 million men
that were draft age 68
never they were they were disqualified
because they were students or physical
limitations or fathers or some other
disqualifying status
then you end up with a bunch of them
that join
the national guard or the reserves which
during vietnam was kind of a way out of
going to vietnam
then you got
guys that joined in the non-combat role
and eventually you get down to that
small percentage of people that stepped
up to fight
there's a section here called avoidance
during the vietnam war almost all of the
nation's affluent youth and a majority
of the middle class escaped the draft by
going to college or claiming a
disability or exemption
a university of notre dame study
estimated that 75 percent of excused men
had actively tried to avoid the draft
throughout the war years many loopholes
were available one of the most famous
cases involved actor george hamilton who
persuaded his draft board to give him a
hardship deferment because he was the
sole support of his mother who lived in
his hollywood mansion and relied on his
200 000 annual income
which would be 1.375 million in today's
dollars
men in certain occupations such as
engineers farmers teachers ministers and
divinity students won automatic
exemptions
fatherhood would could win a deferral so
a number of young men felt pressured to
get married and start a family
he has a little section here talking
about peace children which are basically
guys that had kids so they didn't have
to go to war
a popular way to avoid the draft was to
find a doctor who would attest to a
medical problem such as flat feet
extreme allergies or skin rashes
while he was a student at harvard writer
james fallows recalled sympathetic
medical students helped us in helps us
search for disqualifying conditions that
we in our many good years of good health
might have overlooked for 120 a young
man could purchase a psychological
disqualification
there are reputer quote there are
reputable anti-war psychiatrists who
will pull put one through a series of
personality tests to find some
tendencies they can distort end quote
that's from a harvard graduate
undergraduate
having a letter from a doctor was a sure
way to win a medical exemption for
example the induction center in seattle
washington divided men into two groups
those who had letters from doctors and
those that did not everyone with a
letter got an exemption no matter what
the letter said
induction centers rarely had the time to
contest what an outside expert said
using letters demonstrated the
advantages held by middle-class men who
had easy access to sympathetic physician
working class and poor men
either had no such access or they were
unaware that a doctor's letter was an
option
some men gained disqualifications by
contriving to fail their pre-induction
physical exams a university of michigan
student ate three large peaches each
night for six months so that he exceeded
the military's weight limit for his
height
he was disqualified some men jabbed
their arms with needles to pass
themselves off as heroin addicts
he goes on talking about people that
were getting or getting braces i guess
you weren't allowed to have braces so
he'd get people
dentists would charge a thousand to two
thousand dollars which in today's money
is between seven and fourteen thousand
dollars to get braces put on so now you
don't get drafted
i had a neighbor
i might have told you this before
i had a neighbor who she was older lady
you know he's like our neighbor's mom or
whatever she said her brother
dodged the giraffe by drinking soy sauce
and getting high blood pressure
so just medically exempt or whatever
because of high blood pressure and that
was like a thing like and
other people like his friends or
whatever would do that as well trick so
they wouldn't have wondered how much soy
sauce they had to drink i know right
but blood pressure is like
that seems like something you can just
sort of cure with like even like the
weight thing it's like probably just
lose weight or whatever like well do
this and or even like blood pressure
like if you change your diet even just a
little bit like okay so i went to the
doctor coincidentally today just to get
you know check up normal stuff and they
take your blood pressure and the the
doctor said
there's a thing called white coat
syndrome you ever heard of that no i
never did either until today and i was
like oh what is that it's like people's
blood pressure will rise because just
because they yeah just because they're
nervous in the doctor's office that's
how blood pressure is
so now i'm thinking back it's like bro
that's you can i mean shoot braces bruh
these are some really low standard
medical exemption scenarios yeah so on
one hand
the bar is really low
well that's the thing it's going to get
lower
but it's kind of high in a way is what
i'm saying yeah this is early though
right this is oh yeah and this is also
this is also
they didn't
they they didn't lower this part of the
bar right they lowered other parts of
the bar yeah right
so they made it so that some
rich or middle-class person that access
to a to a freaking dentist and the money
to pay for braces
could all of a sudden get exempt but if
you don't know about that little trick
because you're
from some place that doesn't have that
kind of access or doesn't have that kind
of money or doesn't have that kind of
information
but no google how do i get out of the
draft
there's a lot of that right in a way i
mean that's a that's a spectrum too
where like
isn't that like a typical thing people
might say about the
criminal justice right where it's like
if you can afford a good lawyer kind of
a thing you know yeah good lawyer makes
it get away with a lot a good lawyer
it makes a huge difference a huge
difference
if you have access to that good lawyer
yeah as opposed to not having access to
a good lawyer
either because they you don't know about
it or because you don't have the money
for it yeah for a hundred percent
[Applause]
check this out professional football
players were virtually immune to being
drafted
in 1966 selective service grabbed only
two
of
960 pro players many of the rest finding
refuge in the national guard or reserves
we have an arrangement with the
baltimore colts major general george
gelsen jr of the maryland national guard
set in 1966 when they have a player with
a military problem they send him to us
end quote the dallas cowboys had 10
players assigned to the same national
guard division at one time this is a
freaking scam
the most sensational football star of
the era the new york jets quarterback
joe namath
was excused from service on grounds that
his frequently injured knees made him
unfit for combat
yet he continued to play bone-crushing
football on sunday afternoons by the way
three years after that he won the super
bowl
if a young man refused to submit to the
draft he was a he was subject to arrest
and imprisonment to escape this fate
over 40 000 american youth fled to
countries that were willing to give them
asylum including canada sweden and
france
about 171 000 men refused to submit to
the draft because they were
conscientious objectors
whose religious or moral beliefs forbade
them to kill in any war or in the case
of vietnam war
a war they considered unjust some of
them were excused by local draft boards
while about 96 000 agreed to alternative
service in jobs
such as medics
an estimated 4 000 conscientious
objectors were given long prison terms
usually five years
yeah and what's jacked up about that is
if you're if you're honest and say look
i don't want to go fight because i don't
believe in the war
you're going to jail meanwhile someone
that's getting braces is like clear
some draft avoiders felt remorse over
their actions when he was 66 years old
film and tv actor john lithgow revealed
that while he was in his 20s he wanted
disqualification by wearing urine soaked
clothes and pretending to be insane
during a pre-induction interview a sense
of shame he said stayed with me for
years and has never entirely disappeared
some of that shame had to do with the
appalling suffering caused by the
vietnam war suffering that i so
conveniently avoided
novelist mark halperin
in an address at west point in 1992 told
the cadets that during the vietnam war i
dodged the draft and i was wrong this is
regret that i will carry to my grave
former vice president dick cheney who
spent the war in college in graduate
school
sought and received five deferments from
his draft board
four student deferments and one hardship
deferment
even though he was pro-war
that's freaking unique isn't it
i'm pro-war just not for me
years later when he was one of the prime
architects of the war in iraq and was
accused of being a hypocrite for sending
thousands of men into combat he
justified his vietnam era behavior in
this way quote i had other priorities in
the 60s than military service i don't
regret the decisions i made end quote
okay
[Music]
you don't regret the decisions you made
got it there dick
reacting to comments by cheney and other
successful politicians paul marks that
drafty in the korean war wrote the
baltimore sun quote for every draft of
voider
someone else was made to serve in order
to meet the military's quotas that
someone else might very well have been
killed in vietnam many of america's most
accomplished young men were ready to
pass the buck and let someone else
someone less sophisticated and
knowledgeable make the sacrifices while
they pursued their personal ambitions
end quote
joining the national guard to reserves
was a popular option because relatively
few guardsmen and reservists were sent
to vietnam
again this is totally different now
and national guard and reserve were
deployed all the time in iraq and
afghanistan
out of every one million men who
enlisted in the national guard and
reserves during the vietnam era only 15
000 of them actually served in vietnam
that's a tiny percentage
alan vanaman who served in a combat
artillery unit in vietnam in
1968-1969 said i trained with several
hundred country boys from louisiana and
alabama who were bound for national
guard units
they were as they gleefully put it ng
not going
some men who avoided the draft would
later become prominent leaders such as
bill clinton and mitt romney
but in fairness it should be noted that
a few young men who later became
national leaders served in vietnam and
risked their lives for example three men
who were members of u.s senate at the
same time chuck hagel john kerry and
john mccain were decorated heroes of
combat in vietnam
says here although some affluent men
suffered in vietnam the typical infantry
platoon was made up of minorities the
poor and the working class with a
sprinkling of middle class youth
san antonio lawyer maury maverick jr
recalled that during the war my friends
at the local office of the american
friends service committee placed a cross
on the map of san antonio at the home
address of each person killed in combat
on the west side where the
mexican-americans lived there was a sea
of crosses
in alamo heights
almost park in terrell hills where the
rich people live there were virtually no
crosses at all
most of america's privileged elite
seemed unbothered by the unfair burden
placed on men on the lower rungs of
society but there were some leaders who
were angry and indignant
in 1966
kingman brewster the president of yale
university used his address to the
graduating seniors to denounce a system
that had drafted quote
only those who cannot hide in the
endless catacombs of formal education
so
yeah this is freaking
just pisses you off to hear this [__]
this is going into magnus mayor
mcnamara's plan
the year's 1966 was crunch time for the
american military because so many middle
class american males were avoiding the
draft the military faced the prospect of
serious manpower shortages
because most the men did not volunteer
to extend their tour of duty thousands
of fresh troops had to be deployed to
vietnam every month to replace the
thousands that were departing
to supply extra troops that were
urgently needed president johnson was
faced with a tough choice
here you go president johnson he could
have revoked student deferments and
forced thousands of college boys into
the army or he could have used the one
million men in the national guard and
reserves but either action would have
angered the vote powerful middle class
so instead he turned to the working
class and the poor
god what a [__] bird
here however he also found trouble
rounding up enough eligible men
there are plenty of men of the right age
in the poorer neighborhoods but many of
them have flunked the military's
entrance exam
the armed forces qualification test
that's what i kicked the podcast off
with johnson and defense secretary
mcnamara desperately needed them however
so they lowered the standards for
passing the afqt suddenly thousands of
low aptitude men once declared
unacceptable because of low afqt scores
were now subject to the draft johnson
and mcnamara tried to make their action
appear to be based on humanitarian
compassion
with much fanfare at the 1966 national
convention of the veterans of foreign
wars mcnamara unveiled his plan to
salvage and rehabilitate a hundred
thousand substandard men each year hence
the official title project a hundred
thousand
though the men may have failed in these
subjects
in school they wouldn't fail now because
the military was quote the world's
greatest educator of skilled manpower
end quote mcnamara once considered one
of the most brilliant men in america
he had made a name for himself as one of
the whiz kids who revitalized ford motor
company believed that he could raise the
intelligence of low ability men through
a use of video tapes and closed circuit
tv lessons
quote a low aptitude student can use
video tapes as an aid to his formal
instruction and end by
becoming as proficient as a high
aptitude student end quote
in his starry eyed belief that
videotapes could dramatically transform
slow learners mcnamara was revealing the
same blind faith in the power of
technology that deluded him into
thinking that he could outsmart the
enemy in vietnam by using calculators
computers and statistical analysis
according to biographer deborah shapley
mcnamara was quote a naive believer in
technological mirrors miracles end quote
and announcing project a hundred
thousand mcn never said a word about
combat
to hear him would have thought men were
going not off to war but off to school
in his view the military was doing them
a favor when they got out of the service
they would have valuable skills and
self-confidence with which they could
get good-paying jobs in the civilian
market
it's leading advocate leading average of
this program
daniel patrick moynihan a sociologist
who later became a u.s senator from new
york whose argument went like this the
best way to solve poverty in america is
to draft the hundreds of thousands of
young men being rejected annually as
unfit for military service take inner
city blacks and poor rural whites both
groups tending to be lazy and fond of
booze and put them into uniform instill
discipline train them to bathe daily
salute and take orders teach them a
marketable skill at the end of the
couple years you'll have transformed
lazy unmotivated slackers into
hard-working law-abiding citizens
shit's unbelievable right
[Applause]
now there was pushback there was push
back from the from the uniformed
military so so you got mcnamara who's
the secretary of defense you know he's a
civilian but he's get he's presenting
this great plan
and
the the leadership inside the military
was going hey this [__] ain't going to
work
and mcnamara tells johnson mcnamara told
johnson that uniformed officers in the
defense department were opposed to
drafting low aptitude men because quote
they don't want to be in the business of
dealing with morons and [__] camps
the army doesn't want to be thought of
as a rehabilitation agency end quote
but
mcnamara who's a [__] arrogant guy
and thinks he's smart just pushes this
program anyways
between october 1st in 1966 and december
31st 1971 which the dates of the
official program project 100 000 took in
some
354 000 men 91 percent of them based on
lowered mental standards the remaining
nine percent because of less less
stringent physical standards
project 100 000 men were on average 20
years old
half came from the south 41 were
minorities
some 46 were draftees while the
remaining 54 were volunteers however as
i pointed out earlier the term volunteer
is misleading military recruiters would
get the names of low-scoring men who
were now acceptable to the armed forces
and visit them to steer them toward the
three-year hitch
the recruiters would tell them if if
they waited for the draft they'd only
serve two years but almost certainly end
up in an infantry tune in vietnam
but if they signed up for three years
they would be assigned to a non-combat
job there was however a big catch the
military did not have to honor any oral
promises made by a recruiter
a recruiter might promise a man a job
like helicopter maintenance but after
basic training when it was time to go to
a specialized school the military could
decide that his test scores were not
high enough to call qualify for
helicopter maintenance or in some cases
he could be sent to helicopter
maintenance school and if he flunked
during training he was subject to
transfer to infantry
thousands of three-year projects 100 000
volunteers ended up in infantry because
of this catch
many critics denounce this fraudulent
behavior
project a hundred thousand men were
assigned to all major branches of the
armed forces 71 to the army 10 percent
of the marine corps 10 percent of the
navy 9 of the air force
brings me back to that one book and all
this stuff is going on all these people
avoiding we we covered that one book
called company commander and the guy's
going through uh army oc army officer
candidates gold and they're like where
do you i think i think that's what
bucket was i think it was the book
company commander but you have to write
down your three choices of where you
want to get stationed he writes the
entry platoon commander for triple three
commander infantry commander cotton
and all these other people just avoiding
fighting
it's hard for me
just straight up to understand the
perspective like when i read this and i
read that
all these 68 of people avoided the draft
like i read that it doesn't it's hard
for me to compute that it's hard for me
to compute
like
being a man and being like oh a bunch of
people are going to go fight a war i'm
going to hide over here
it's hard for me to compute that i got
to be honest with you
yeah that makes sense to me that it'd be
free it's hard for me to understand it
what what kind of human you have to be
now
if you're like hey
actively saying look i don't believe in
this war i actually get that i actually
get that if someone says looks listen we
shouldn't be over there fighting and i'm
not going and you want to send me to
jail send me to jail you want to do you
want to make me uh serve in some other
capacity okay but i'm not going to go
fight that war if you do that
i'll respect you yeah right if you hide
and get braces
and get a letter from a psychologist
yeah and that's what you do no i i it i
cannot believe that the numbers are that
high it's crazy
yeah and and
being in your presence for a long time
and kind of reading this book with you
that makes sense
but if you think back to
let's say a 20 year old
person
who
isn't like you like maybe that maybe
maybe they do have my maybe their middle
class and they got normal stuff quote
unquote normal stuff going on they're
not really into politics or history or
nothing like that they're just into
normal stuff
and
then they hear on the news yeah hey
there's a war going on
and
you know what you don't have a choice
you have to fight it he was like i don't
want to go in the military like that was
never my plan that was never nothing
in fact i don't want to just be a doctor
well that's a good point and the good
point the great point that you're making
is a point that i've actually been
making a lot lately and i talked about
it when i was on with rogan which is
when you impose something on someone
they reject it so that's a great example
you impose the draft on people they're
going to get freaking pissed off they're
going to get nervous they're going to
run away from it so that's a good point
and when i take that into an account
then i understand it better so thank you
for helping me understand a little bit
better when someone says hey you're
going to war and you that's not part of
your thing
you kind of think wait a second i'm not
going to war where's the dentist i need
some braces over here
but even with that being said so i
understand that's a good point but even
that being said
the fact that that the numbers are that
large that it was the thing to go get
braces
that it was a thing that people were
writing home from college going don't
worry mom i gotta get a letter from a
psychologist we have to pay 125 dollars
and they'll write up a report of that
was a thing it wasn't like a rare case
yeah but and then even then again from
you know
our perspective
when it's done with in in you know uh
when things kind of sort themselves out
like that makes sense for sure to to
maybe have trouble seeing that but again
think think about how it was probably
like for anything like hey what if your
neighbor well what if hey look i grew up
on you know fifth street and bro we're
not into politics we're into we play
baseball and yeah i heard about this
quote-unquote war
i don't know anyone in the military i
don't know anyone not one single person
in fact i just i heard of you know my
neighbor's
cousin that lives in the other side of
the country one in the military i don't
know anyone in the military i'm you know
i want to be a dentist i want to be a
lawyer and
you know i want to be a fireman
and that's the culture and then it's
like oh my gosh you know you hear it on
the news you get in the mail whatever
you're you gotta register for the draft
which is this
you have to go in the military and you
gotta go fight this war that you don't
know anything about you don't know
anything in the military and now you
have to do it otherwise you go to jail
so and it's like damn now i gotta risk
my life for something i don't really
know about not necessarily that i'm
against or for or nothing like that i
just don't really know about it you're
18 years old i don't know about that
kind of stuff right now
and then your neighbor goes and it's
like hey i can't go my i got flat feet
and i'm like oh wait do i have fl i
don't even know if i have flat feet let
me go in the
doctor or whatever let's see what up oh
this guy oh i had braces i don't well
let me go see if i need some braces
because i don't want to go either none
of us want to go we never did
and all i have to do is you know and
then you start to just get that culture
where it's not shameful to go get braces
yeah well that's a big piece of it that
that's those are all great points and
it's you're you're you're right and
imposing things on people
and just like this just like imposing
the draft that's why people was like
don't you think everyone should serve in
the military i always
generally think
not really because when you start
imposing things on people hey would it
be good yes would it be good to do some
kind of service would it be good to
understand what it's like to be in the
military or go overseas into yes that
stuff would all be great but when you
start imposing things on people so
you're right i guess i was having a
little bit of an allergic reaction to
this yes sir i was having a little bit
of a maybe a lot of bit of an allergic
reaction well that's a bias right the um
it's curse of knowledge or i don't know
something where you can't no no yeah and
i guess it's also i guess what makes me
most frustrated
is that it's like the entire chain of
command right you got lyndon johnson the
president you got the second they're all
making these moves
that are based on
helping people hey we're not going to
you know you go to college it's all a
scam
that's what's pissing me off i guess
more than anything else is that it's a
scam and the other thing is
if you
if you are going to go to war right you
you should be able to explain why we're
going to war and the people should be
able to say yeah that actually makes
sense and then you go to war and you
realize that people are going to get
killed and you realize you're going to
kill some bad people and you realize
that some civilians are going to die as
well all those things talk about that
stuff all the time
all that stuff is going to happen and
also if you say hey here's we're going
to war and you cannot explain why and
the populist goes hey dude what are we
doing as soon as you got people going
hey i'm gonna go get freaking uh gonna
go piss on myself so i don't have to go
and now you got a whole group a whole
class of people that are saying we don't
want to fight maybe we should reconsider
what what we're doing there because
that's a problem
you know if you're in charge of a
company or you're in charge of a platoon
you say hey we're going to go over this
hill and the whole platoon or two-thirds
of the platoon goes hey boss i'm not so
sure about that or you're in a company
you say we're gonna go in this new
market area and a bunch of your
leadership and a bunch of your mid-level
managers say hey boss
i don't want to go into that market area
what about you
i don't want to go what about you i
don't want to go okay you have to go
into that market area
maybe you should reconsider what you're
doing you're not smarter than everybody
else that's a problem
[Applause]
going back to this book
[Music]
most project 100 000 men were graduated
from basic training even if even if
company commanders
had to cheat to get them through after
leaving basic training project hundred
thousand men were sent to ait which is
advanced individual training to learn
infantry tactics or if they were lucky
specialized skills
such as
radio telephone operator rto props
called the [__] core at fort polk
project hundred thousand men were quote
pretty damn bad recalled one officer
somebody had to help them to get dressed
in the morning they couldn't understand
what was going on another officer said
lots of these guys just weren't fit to
do a job i had to help one buy a
toothbrush and pack his bags so he could
report to another duty station
fast forward a little bit
most of the 500 and
most of the 354 000 men of project 100k
went to vietnam
with about half of them assigned to
combat units which is just insane
a total of 5 478 of these men died while
in service most them in combat their
fatality rate was three times that of
the other gis though precise figures are
unavailable
all of these tallies would be higher if
we knew the number of deaths and
injuries of substandard men who were not
officially counted in project hundred
thousand according to colonel david
hackworth
and salute
who fought in both korea and vietnam
wars and became one of the most highly
decorated warriors in american history
project quote project 100 000 was
implemented to produce more grunts for
the killing fields of vietnam
it took unfit recruits from the bottom
of the barrel and rushed them to vietnam
the result was human applesauce
he added that
for fighting in combat quote 10 smart
and fit soldiers are better than 100 out
of shape dummies end quote and that's
that's you know you're what you're the
comments you were bringing up earlier
you know i mean get three guys a good
eight guys
that's his ratio he's giving up 10 to
100. is that a hyperbole a little
exaggerated maybe yeah but
if you're talking about people that
can't tie their shoes it might not be
hyperbole it might be reality yeah
yeah nonetheless he's making the point
yeah that that's a big deal
one of one veteran who had good reason
to be dismayed by the deaths of project
hundred thousand men in vietnam was
leslie john shellhace who had been
wounded in the battle of bulge in world
war ii and had served as a lieutenant
colonel under mcnamara at the pentagon
in the late 1960s he said he played a
central role in planning for a project
hundred thousand which he considered a
bad idea from the start
we meaning the pentagon planners
resisted project hundred thousand
because we knew that wars are not won by
using marginal manpower as cannon fodder
but rather by risking and sometimes
losing
the flower of a nation's youth end quote
can you imagine being in charge of
something and you're getting all this
resistance from people that actually do
that for a living and you force it down
their throats anyways
that's again to your point earlier
earlier which is a reference to my point
when you impose things on people it's a
bad move
lieutenant paul d walker who served in
viet oh and by the way you know what
you've heard me say that imposing things
on people doesn't work it doesn't
clearly because you impose the draft on
people and they avoid it they get braces
they piss on themselves whatever so you
think oh we'll just draft me it doesn't
work it doesn't work to impose things on
people
lieutenant paul d walker who served in
vietnam as a platoon leader in the
armored cavalry of the first infantry
division wrote about the worst episode
during his tour of duty we had not seen
a single enemy soldier in two days of
combat operations
resulting in three killed ten wounded
and three vehicles destroyed
he blamed the four project hundred
thousand men in his platoon who
accounted for more than their share of
casualties and accidents he said that
some of the project hundred thousand men
were quote virtually untrainable and
never should have been allowed into the
military and certainly not sent into
combat
fast forward a little bit not only were
low-quality enlisted men sent to vietnam
said westmoreland but low-quality
officers as well he cited lieutenant
william kelly convicted in the murder of
more than a hundred unarmed citizens in
the battle of in the in the milei
massacre in 1968.
according to arnold r isaacs the vietnam
war correspondent for the baltimore sun
cali quote flunked out of palm beach
junior college with two c's a d and four
f's in his first year and reportedly
managed to get through officer candidate
school without even learning how to read
a map or use a compass end quote
marine corps colonel robert d heinle
said that the army had to take cali
quote because no one else was available
his own attorney used cali's low
intelligence as a courtroom defense the
army he said was to blame from milai
massacre
because it had lowered mental standards
men if it hadn't lowered mental
standards men like cali never would have
been commissioned
richard a gabriel who spent 22 years as
a us army officer says quote even the
staunchest defenders of the army agree
that in normal times a man of lieutenant
cali's intelligence and predispositions
would never have been allowed to hold a
commission
[Applause]
talking about that pushback during the
early years the war when mcnamara was
campaigning to draft lower aptitude men
wise military commanders and veterans
were warning against this his misguided
idea for example in 1964 two years
before project 100k was launched an
impassioned article appeared in the
american bar association journal by
texas attorney and reserve air force
captain william f walsh who wrote
warfare is steadily growing more complex
the day is passed when an effective
soldier need only the intelligence to
point a musket downhill and obey an
order don't fire to listen till you see
the whites of their eyes
service in the armed forces today
requires an alert questioning mind
simply to master the technology of
weapons and tactics there is likely to
be no room for the low iq soldier the
warm body who cannot or will not cut the
mustard that man is going to get in the
way of those who will have to do the job
end quote this guy was hearing this
despite such warnings mcnamara plowed
ahead and the results are disastrous
one of the biggest
blunders of our vietnam experience said
lieutenant colonel charles l armstrong
of the marine corps was the project
hundred thousand folly of taking on
board marginally qualified individuals
under the mistaken watchword of the
infantry doesn't have to be real smart
dumb grunt however is not a complete
phrase
dumb dead grunt is you don't have to be
a fulbright scholar
you don't have to be a fulbright scholar
to be a good rifleman
but you can't be stupid
survive in combat you had to be smart
you had to know how to use your rifle
effectively and keep it clean and
operable how to navigate through jungles
and rice paddies without alerting the
enemy and how to communicate and
cooperate with other members of your
team sad to say many low aptitude men
were not smart enough to be successful
in combat and as a result they were
killed or wounded
barry romo and his nephew robert ended
up in vietnam at the same time
i loved robert like a brother we grew up
together he was only one month younger
barry served in infantry as a platoon
leader in 1967 to 1968 saw a lot of
combat winning a bronze star for his
courage on the battlefield during his
tour he learned that robert had been
drafted and was being trained in fort
lewis washington to be an infantryman
destined for vietnam barry was alarmed
because robert was quote very slow and
had failed the army's mental test but
then along came project 100k lowering
standards and making him draftable a
host of people his relatives his
comrades at fort lewis his sergeants and
officers wrote to the commanding general
at fort lewis asking that robert not be
sent into combat because as one relative
put it quote he would die
but the general turned down the request
once in vietnam robert was sent to an
infantry unit near the border for north
vietnam one of the most dangerous combat
areas during a patrol he was shot in the
neck while trying to help a wounded
friend
he did not die instantly but heavy
gunfire kept the medic from reaching him
he drowned in his own blood said barry
looking back barry said that robert
really didn't have much luck
while others were getting draft
deferments he was drafted while
congressionals while congression while
congressman's sons were getting four f's
which were exemptions for braces on
their teeth robert was drafted as part
of project 100k
in a speech delivered 42 years later
barry romo said that the family had
never recovered from losing robert quote
his death almost destroyed us with anger
and sorrow end quote
fast forward a little bit here mental
slowness and extreme anxiety were among
the worst enemies of project 100k men in
combat
while training at fort benning says
lieutenant colonel robert kimball a
combat veteran of vietnam war we had the
idea cemented into our heads that there
were two kinds of soldiers the quick and
the dead
to survive in combat you had to be quick
to recognize a threat and quick to
respond to it all soldiers in combat
experience fear and fear causes a
soldier to slow down fear can have a
major impact on whether or not a soldier
survives war
sergeant major francis t mcneve
said that people who were borderline
[__] did not respond fast enough and
that's how people became casualties
marine captain david anthony dawson said
men
who could not understand simple orders
or perform simple tasks clearly posed a
danger to themselves and other members
of the unit he gave the following
example
while serving as a battalion commander
vietnam brigadore general william wise
watch the squad leader give an order for
an ambush patrol the squad leader gave
simple clear order but one marine
couldn't remember any of the crucial
details including the password that
night this marine left the ambush to
relieve himself without telling anyone
when returning he wandered into the kill
zone
the squad leader sprang the ambush
and his squad killed him
the dull-witted soldier said pentagon
official eliot conan cohen
does not simply get himself killed he
causes the deaths of others as well
according to chief warrant officer for
william s tuttle a vietnam veteran if
you take someone with an iq of 40 and
give him a rifle he's more dangerous to
you than he is to the enemy
there's another fast forward a little
bit new inexperienced men in army and
marine units especially project 100k men
had a high rate of getting themselves
and their comrades wounded and killed in
the first few months and of their tours
in vietnam
james r ebert found that 43 percent of
army fatalities happen in the first
three months
what sucks about reading that statistic
is you realize that there's training
that you could do to get better to get
prepared
and it just wasn't happening
john l ward rejoiced when project 100k
came into his life
he grew up in poverty in a black
neighborhood of glasgow missouri living
in a shanty that had no running water
and he talks about john l ward's
situation
he
had taken the test to try and see if he
could get in to the
military didn't
wasn't good enough his score wasn't high
enough then he says then to my utter
surprise the marine corps recruiter
showed up and explained to me that i
could join them now despite the low test
score thanks to project 100k and the
newly lowered standards i could now
pursue my dream of getting out of
glasgow
and seeing the world
and this is an example it gives this guy
john l ward as an example of a guy that
couldn't pass the test because he was
uneducated
but not because he wasn't smart so he
had what he calls native intelligence
meaning he hadn't gone to school so he
never learned math or whatever but he
but he actually was a smart human
and so when he became a marine he did
well
ward became a proud marine and quickly
won a promotion of corporal
unfortunately his dreams were shattered
in vietnam during the night of august
18th 1968 enemy troops attacked and
overran a marine bunker at fu law
killing 17 marines and wounding many
more ward suffered severe injuries and
he was returned to the united states for
a long and painful recovery
after leaving the service with rank of
sergeant ward spent 15 years just trying
to survive his physical and mental
torments eventually he became a
counselor and advocate for project 100k
veterans in 2012 he wrote a book
entitled [__] core
about his experience as one of
mcnamara's morons a term that he hated
but nevertheless embraced to remind
america that project 100k was
insensitive morally unjust and inhumane
he stated that men who were accepted
under mcnamara's program served their
country honorably even with our
so-called limited abilities we were
willing to lay down our lives for our
country
but the program was carried out in a
morally shameful manner project 100k men
were overrepresented in combat and they
died in disproportionate numbers those
who managed to survive were quote thrown
back into society without skills
promised us many of the men were
homeless and suffered isolation
unemployment drug addiction and medical
neglect
many failed to receive the assistance
that they were supposed to receive from
the u.s department of affairs
because the national guard and reserves
were relatively safe avenues for
military service they were filled to
capacity with middle class and wealthy
men mostly white
you usually had to have connections to
get in poor and working class men
especially blacks were excluded
in 1968 the army national guard was only
1.26 percent black
in mississippi where blacks made up 42
percent of the population
only one black man was admitted to the
365 man mississippi national guard
so again
if you got the right connections
in this case oh if you're a white dude
you can sneak into the national guard
and avoid going to war
in 1972 professor leslie
fiedler
who knew of hundreds of young people at
his college
state university of new york at buffalo
slowly realized that he knew not a
single vietnam veteran
this is 1972.
i had never known a single family that
had lost a son in vietnam the reason he
concluded was that vietnam was the first
war
that quote has been fought for us by our
servants the actual fighting of the war
has become more and more exclusively an
occupation of the exploited and
dispossessed end quote
during the vietnam war congressman
william a steiger of wisconsin said the
draft as a the draft survives as a last
vestige of the ancient custom whereby
the rich and powerful force the poor and
weak to provide service at substance
wages
while it was true that men had grown up
in poverty were disproportionately
represented in combat i don't want to
leave the impression that only the
extremely poor fought in vietnam
in infantry units the poor were joined
by many men from working class families
described by historian christian g
appease as quote the 19 year old
children of waitresses factory workers
truck drivers secretaries firefighters
carpenters custodians police officers
sales people
clerks mechanics miners and farm workers
end quote men from lower economic levels
poor and working class comprised 80
percent of the combat forces while the
remaining 20 percent came from the
middle class half of them serving as
officers
i think i have my answer next time
somebody asked me about the draft my dr
my answer is no
because this is the kind of government
[__] that goes down
yeah that's and that's another one right
another reason why what i mean kind of
rewind back to why
someone would dodge the draft in
whatever way
is yeah the straight up government is
telling
you you got to work for them
probably lose your life or what you know
that's in your mind that's what you're
thinking right
you know
work and or kill other people about you
know for reasons that you you're not
completely sure of um and then yes it's
up to the government no
not you government that's imposed it's
imposed man yeah people humans don't
like being have things imposed on here's
the thing okay so taxes right yeah we
don't like taxes no we don't even though
the idea of taxes makes sense you're
like wait a second the government has to
function you know all this stuff and and
the government needs money to function
and do all this stuff so the idea of
taxes
but just like the idea of hey this if i
pitch the draft you like this listen
we're at war we need people
everyone's gonna have to serve we're
gonna do a lottery that sounds fair
right because that's what it was it was
a lottery based on what day you were
born
so hey look this is what we're going to
do
if we're everyone we're at a war we need
people we're going to do a draft
we're going to do a lottery if you get
picked you got to go you'd be like
you know what don't really like it but
it seems like the fair thing to do cool
i'm down let's do the draft right
because that's kind of the pitch
but then but then you go wait i want my
son to go well
send yourself into college yeah yeah
okay and then we work around the voting
thing
we that way we i'm not working around
the voting thing that way we please the
group that's going to get the most
out of this scenario yeah
what do what would be your okay let's
say
hypothetic you need a draft scenario
like basically the draft was a solution
to this
an issue right a problem we need people
or whatever what would be your off the
top of your head way to go about doing
that well first of all
i'm thinking that if i'm doing something
where the only way i can get the people
to come and fight is to force them i
there's something i'm doing something
wrong
it could be that i'm explaining to
everyone wrong why this is important
yeah which it's hard to explain to
someone in 1968 that hey
this is a threat to us
and why is that well because it's it's
far away yeah and so if you can't
explain that maybe you need to rethink
what your strategy is
people get cl people's egos get in the
way they get addicted to their plan they
believe their own [__] you get a guy
like mcnamara and and all the people
that surrounded him it was ridiculous
and and
johnson same thing
like these these guys have
johnson knew that we weren't going to
win vietnam halfway through
and continued to send troops there and
continue to have americans get killed
so you would have started just
you know i mean that makes sense you
would say that start with yourself first
like if you're in charge of the word
like start with the beginning first like
is this a
is this solution
a real solution or is it adding to
another problem if i can't articulate to
my team
why we why we need to do something then
i need to either
develop my articulation more come up
with those reasons make them clear to
everyone so everyone goes yeah you know
what this is a rough
rough solution but it's the only
solution we get it we're on board yeah
that's why you hear me talk i don't i i
the amount of times that i ordered my
troops to do something is zero there are
times all right listen enough debate
this is what we're doing shut up i never
had to do that
because if you can say hey listen here's
what here's the goal that we got to get
accomplished here's why we're doing it
yeah i'm open to suggestions if you can
think of a better way
if we you can't think of a better way
what do you think of this idea and
everyone says yeah that sounds pretty
good and there's people that freak out
and get all scared like
sometimes you got to just say shut up
and do it you actually don't have to do
that you actually don't have to do that
now could we be in a situation in a gun
fight where i'm like echo go take that
building over there yeah that could
happen and you'll be like cool got it
boss or you'll be like hold on i can't
take that building there's enemy in it
i'll take this other one i go cool but
you understand what we're trying to do
so the idea of imposing things on people
is wrong
it's wrong to impose things on people
when was
the era of like the propaganda posters
and all that was always even today in
vietnam
yeah we make propaganda posters well
okay so but you know how like there was
like in a very distinct era world war
two is the one you're talking about yeah
yeah okay so to me
and i don't know what do i know pretty
much nothing
but that being said
that seems like i see what they were
doing there i see what they're it's
essentially a marketing campaign
what do you mean essentially that is a
marketing event
sometimes you go past marketing into
propaganda okay no kind of thing kind of
a thing and that's what i mean okay of
course but you're right either way the
the the
it feels like and it it's kind of a
different way of maybe
yeah like it's a different way of saying
what you said where
if you can't convince them
that of a good reason to do this then
you're not it's like something's up
right yeah and here's the deal like when
you're in world war ii
and you're fighting the nazis and the
imperial japanese it ain't a hard sell
yeah bro
these people are trying to take over the
whole world and impose darkness on it
and we gotta go scrap yeah that's what's
about to happen yeah so that's not a
hard sell that's what makes that's why
you have freaking lines or it's after
after september 11th yeah the lines
around the recruiting tim kennedy
remember tim kennedy's like yeah i went
down
to to join after spring bluff there's a
line or that's because it's real evie
it's easy to see why we're doing this
right well what happened if you're not
in the beginning of it i was like okay
we're gonna go fight these people then
after a while they're going wait a
second what are they doing wait why have
we gone through because the south
vietnamese shuffled through three four
five governments
we're to help this government oh well
now it's a new government now it's
another government oh no they're corrupt
this guy got assassinated it's freaking
crazy you start looking over there what
are we doing
so as that stuff starts to build up okay
and that's what pisses me off going back
to this whole draft thing what pisses me
off is this you hear me say this
if someone on the team doesn't like what
we're doing you need to raise your hand
and say hey boss we don't like what's
going on here yeah so if you're getting
drafted and you don't like it what the
proper thing to do is for the country is
to stand up and say hey listen hey
listen i am not going to go do this
because i don't think this is right
because i see we went through four or
five different governments in vietnam it
seems like it's corrupt we don't know
what's happening we're getting guys
killed we're killing civilians we need
to figure this out better before i sign
up and if if 68 of the draftable
populist would have said hey
i'm not gonna go fight not because i
have braces not because i pissed on
myself not because i'm in college but
because i don't think it's the right
thing to do maybe someone says okay we
got to figure out we got to reassess
what's happening right
so
in a way let's go back to the marketing
campaign
expression
so
let me ask you this with a great
marketing campaign can you sell me an
ice cream cone full of [__]
can you
no sir you cannot i think i can know so
if you're trying to sell me an ice cream
cone full of [__]
i'm not gonna buy it yes sir so what you
need to do is say wait my product is
wrong i need to put milk and sugar and
chocolate in here yeah that you need to
make an adjustment not an adjustment on
what you're not an adjustment on your
message on your product yeah
or which i think
what the propaganda posters kinda seems
like this was their their little
approach was um
well some of the ones i seen anyway it's
less about the ice cream cone full of
[__] it's more about
what kind of person has the strength to
endure
an ice cream cone full of [__] yeah it's
kind of like that so that's some
messaging there yeah so okay
but let me ask you this in a straight up
direct question yes sir what would be my
chances of convincing you to eat an ice
cream cone full of [__]
by saying dude if you're tough you can
eat this
there's very few people that are down
for that now if i say listen hey hey
listen this thing this ice cream cone
it's got seaweed
and it's got freaking
clay no clay's not edible it's got
seaweed in it this is a seaweed ice
cream it doesn't taste good but
you got to get some of this
there's a chance i can convince you look
we do do stupid men do dumb [__] all the
time yes sir
because
we just want to prove that we're cool
we're going to prove that we're tough so
there's a difference between trying to
get someone to eat ice
seaweed and someone trying to get
someone to eat [__]
so what i'm saying is if i'm trying to
pitch you
and the only thing i've got as a product
is [__]
it's not going to work
and what i need you to say is hey listen
jocko i appreciate it i'm not gonna eat
[__] it's not happening you can call me
a wimp
you can call me weak you can call me uh
pathetic but i'm not gonna eat [__]
now with the seaweed you'd be like well
dude i don't really wanna be weak i
don't really want to be pathetic so
hand me the hand me the cone we're going
to get it on so there's a there's a
there's a there's a
there's a there's it's close but it's
not the same thing yeah and essentially
it's like you look at the the after
september 11th as an easy sell right
easy sell ice cream there's a spectrum
ice cream cone full of [__] hard cell
hearts we'll say yep and then the
seaweed world war ii world war ii easy
sell
easy it's a pretty easy sell yeah it's a
pretty freaking easy sell they have oh
by the way they attack pearl harbor
what's the sell now we got we got this
you don't have to sell yeah the ice
cream's there everyone's taking it we
want it so on the and this goes on the
spectrum of all things wars whatever
where yeah the easier the sell the less
you got to focus on these marketing
campaigns true the harder the cell the
more you got to focus and be more clever
with it yep
but you also have to be able to say to
yourself you know what what i'm trying
to sell is [__] yeah at the end of the
day
and if you have that then you don't say
well i'm just going to keep forcing it
down people so now you know what you say
hey listen i got to change my product
yeah what i'm trying to sell is wrong
yeah and that's where people get stuck
that's where mcnamara that's where
johnson that's where these people get
stuck because they ca their egos are too
big to admit that this was a dumb idea
and say listen hey we tried this was a
bad plan we didn't realize how corrupt
the vietnamese government was we didn't
realize how strong the viet cong were
we didn't realize how much we were going
to have to sacrifice to get in there and
we're going to cut our losses we're
going to come home we're going to
observe and see what happens
that that's what a a squared away humble
human being would do
going back to the book
william broyles who commanded a marine
infantry platoon in vietnam from 1969 to
1971 said it was not a privilege to be
able to fight it was instead evidence
that one had failed to understand how to
manipulate the system as if anyone not
smart enough to get a deferment or at
least to get a job in the rear was too
dumb to do anything but carry a rifle
wayne johnson who served as a grunt in
vietnam 1968 told me that his squad
leader assigned quote one of mcnamara's
boys to walk point
and justified his action by saying if
anyone has to die better a dummy than
the rest of us
johnson said it was unfair i know but
none of us protested
while he was with the unit he added none
of the point men were injured or killed
fast forward a little be said earlier i
showed and by the way this book is i'm
obviously just skimming the surface here
this book is really
uh fascinating and informative about all
this not just around project hundred
thousand but obviously about the draft
and
spills over to leadership as well
he says earlier i showed how tens of
thousands of middle class and upper
class men beat the draft by employing
such strategies as getting a family
doctor to write a letter attesting to
some minor medical problem by contrast
most low-income youths knew nothing
about how they could manage
their draft status in many cases they
had legitimate problems that should have
kept them from serving such as being
blind in one eye or only having one
kidney but they possessed no awareness
or skills to argue the case
they didn't know that they could go to a
draft board or induction center and
explain their rightful grounds for an
exemption
later if they were abused in basic
training or ait they lacked the skills
to complain to a member of congress
after discharge if they were denied
veterans benefits they didn't know how
to work through the bureaucracy
in my research i found only one case of
a project 100k man or his family using
the tools of protest and persuasion that
middle-class citizens knew how to use in
1969 a father in oregon
bought the fam bought the army's plan to
send sorry fought the army's plan to
send his son whom he described as
[__] with the mental age of a
ten-year-old to vietnam as an
infantryman his mother said he's just a
little boy he'll be killed sure
the parents generated publicity in
oregon newspapers and enlisted the aid
of congress and congressman wendell
wyatt and senator mark hatfield because
of all the negative publicity the army
canceled the youth's assignment to
combat vietnam and sent him instead to
germany to perform clerical tasks that's
only one case
and why that's what he's pointing out is
somebody that's up in the freaking
poor rural area doesn't even understand
oh well you can defer you can you can
try and get out of this
or someone from the ghettos doesn't
understand oh you can you can try
there's a way to get out of this they
haven't heard it yet
going crazy
he says this during my lifetime in
moments of extreme stress anxiety or
panic i have done things that are dumb
and destructive it is humbling and
instructive to remember my own episodes
of dysfunction when i consider the
insane actions of some project 100k men
who were young typically 19 or 20 and
burdened with more anxiety and
vulnerability than i will ever
experience that's a freaking great point
you think about
the things that you've done when you're
stressed out freaked out you've done
dumb things behave badly made bad
decisions because of that
and you're a smart person and imagine
what these other people that are under
more stress in a combat scenario
in a study of intellectually disabled
men at the mental hygiene clinic at the
67th evacuation hospital in queen
qui-non in a six-month period two army
psychiatrists found that project 100k
soldiers were referred to for
psychiatric help 10 times as frequently
as other troops
project 100k men they said seem to have
lowered
stress tolerance and a relative lack of
the usual mechanisms for coping with
stress in a separate study four army
psychiatrists concluded quote
individuals of lower intellectual
capacity have greater difficulty in
adjustment than persons of average
intelligence and thus more frequently
become
psychiatric problems or disciplinary
offenders
end quote
can you imagine that in vietnam
during the war they're studying
intellectually disabled men in the army
in vietnam in combat
god
what a freaking disaster
jim bracewell a helicopter pilot who
commanded an air cavalry squadron in the
mekong delta 1970 tells the story of
mike sanchez not his real name who was a
product of project 100k and never should
have been sent to a war zone as soon as
mike was assigned to an infantry platoon
in the field the young lieutenant
platoon leader realized that a terrible
mistake had been made
he requested that mike be moved to a
rare area while the request was being
processed mike a simple young man who
could neither read nor write remain in
the infantry platoon and was asked to
perform beyond his mental capabilities
the platoon leader was very
compassionate and tried to keep mike
under his wing protecting him from
ridicule from unfeeling soldiers
in return mike developed an intense
loyalty to the lieutenant one day as the
platoon moved through some rice paddies
the men came under heavy fire from the
enemy and they ran for cover as soon as
they reached cover mike looked for his
lieutenant he couldn't find him he
frantically began calling the platoon
leader's name one of the other soldiers
told mike to stop yelling that he had
seen the lieutenant go down and thought
he was dead mike tearfully asked where
he was when he pinpointed lieutenant's
position he shed his equipment including
his rifle and ran through heavy fire to
his lieutenant he scrambled to his young
leader's side and discovered that he was
badly hit in both legs mike didn't know
whether the lieutenant was dead or alive
he made no attempt at first aid it never
occurred to him he simply picked up the
lieutenant as if he were a doll and ran
back to the tree line neither of them
were hit during the dash to the trees
and no one could believe it considering
the intensity of enemy fire
they said the pattern of bullets hitting
the rice paddy patty water all around
them made it seem impossible they were
not hit the lieutenant received first
aid and a short time later was evacuated
by a helicopter he survived
about a month later bracewell said mike
was sent to the rear area to participate
in a parade and receive a silver star
for heroism presented by the commanding
general of his division
as was customary at ceremonies the
general presented the medal and then
chatted with him for a few minutes it
was during this chat that the general
realized that something was not quite
right he ordered his subordinates to
remove mike from combat
that's a that kind of rings of like the
forrest gump scenario you know
and that that section there's some other
there's some other good stories in there
about um
just about guys that did perform like
even though they were not quite
didn't have as much
cognitive capacity they and he's got a
bunch of examples like that
uh bottom of the barrel this section's
called and recalling the day in 1969
when he reported to the induction center
in downtown cleveland ohio for his
pre-induction exam
mark fruitkin said at one point at that
point in the war they were taking just
about anyone they could get misfits flat
foots
the half crippled and the half crazed
and so they had to get more people they
had two ways to get more people
induction centers had a monthly quota
for how many project 100k men they could
take
when they used up their quota they were
instructed to continue to take low
scoring men but not count them as par
part of project 100k
in this way thousands of additional low
iq men were brought into the ranks two
recruiters and induction centers were
pressured to cast a wider net and bring
in thousands of additional men who would
normally fail to qualify for military
duty men with health problems physical
defects psychological disorders criminal
backgrounds or and drug and alcohol
addiction
these second class fellows to use
president johnson's term served a
political goal they spared healthier
wealthier men in the middle class from
being drafted
many military commanders lamented the
skewed priorities that put the playing
of put playing politics ahead of
creating a high quality fighting force
adrian r lewis a retired u.s army major
who taught at west point said the
primary concern of the draft was
pacification of the american people to
disrupt american society as little as
possible providing the armed forces with
the best men possible was at best a
secondary consideration
that's just about politics man
as the military grew more and more
desperate for manpower induction centers
grabbed every warm body they could find
even men with serious medical conditions
such as asthma high blood pressure
hearing loss
carlos martinez who said he grew up in
the streets and orphanages of bronx in
brooklyn was rejected by the military in
1964 as physically unfit for service but
in 1967 lo and behold he was now fit we
were the bottom of the barrel he said i
was almost legally blind
but when we got down to the induction
station in 1967 it wasn't really about
the physicals
it was like you were being taken
the assumption was that the assumption
was already made that you were available
everybody was taken the only way you
don't pass is if you don't have a leg
fast forward a little bit more among the
ranks of the armed forces in 1966 1971
were
men who had been unacceptable because
their body size for example too heavy
too thin too short
until project 100k suddenly made them
fair gain
nine percent of project 100k men were
accepted because of new less stringent
physical standards so 91 was mental
but there was nine percent that just
lowered the physical standards
because they were different
in quotes
these men were often harassed and given
humiliating names overweight men were
ridiculed with names such as fatty
lardass and porky exclusively
excessively thin men skin and bones and
tiny men run and [__]
army veteran john ketwig tells of a
trainee called fatso at fort dix new
jersey who committed suicide after
suffering horrendous cruelty at the
hands of a sadistic sergeant
once he had been a law student said
kettwig
he had been called to do his duty he had
a wife
and criminals as well for many ncos and
officers the pentagon policy that caused
most anger and outrage in the later
years of the war was the relaxation of
so-called moral standards men who had
been convicted of serious crimes like
armed robbery were supposed to be
disqualified from service but recruiters
and induction centers were given the
authority to grant moral waivers to
bring them into the ranks in a common
scenario a judge working in
collaboration with the recruiter would
give a young offender a choice go to
jail or join the army or the marine
corps
when a judge and recruiter worked out a
deal the procedure was known as punitive
enlistment
criminal behavior was often accompanied
by alcohol and drug abuse if a man had a
police record for drunk driving or
intoxicated assaults he would have been
rejected in the days before the vietnam
war but after the war became began
because of the manpower shortages he was
accepted
that punitive enlistment
how much do you know about uh what like
don't do they do that now i heard of
that
they don't do it anymore
i would hear guys saying that even when
i got in or
either
jail or the
military i know a guy okay straight up
the judge that's what he told him oh
okay that's that's then then still
happens how long ago was that
it's hard to get in the military right
now
yeah it was before i don't know why i i
don't know but he is younger than me
so i know yeah i guess it's a thing i do
i definitely knew people that
told stories like that but there's a lot
of people especially when you first get
in the military a lot of stories you
know oh true everyone was a you know
drafted to play in the nfl but then they
chose this
you know everyone's a d1 football player
or a golden gloves boxer and like
there's a lot of stories you hear or you
know i was like thug you know i was
i was either i come to jail or come here
so you hear a lot of stories you don't
know which ones to believe kind of when
you first get in yeah i
i believe this guy i guess
i mean
yeah i believe them but
yeah who knows i i don't i didn't grow
up with them or nothing if you know the
guy yeah and like he seems legit then
maybe it's true yeah yeah
but they're i'm just saying when you get
in the military especially boot camp
there's a lot of people say a lot of
weird stories man they make up a lot of
stuff okay to try and sound cool
yeah but we know that it did happen i
mean clearly it had a name i was that's
the first time i'd ever heard that name
punitive enlistment i've never heard
that before or maybe now it's like less
like official you know or something like
that yeah
yeah maybe it's less official now i know
it's harder to get the military now like
if you have
criminal record it's really hard to get
in the military now
so
check um
in the final years the war men who were
violent angry or disturbed became a
significant presence in the army and
marine corps according to many officers
they were responsible for a serious
breakdown of discipline in the troops of
vietnam in 1971 colonel
robert d heinel wrote in armed forces
general this is in 1971 he wrote this
our army now that now remains in vietnam
is an estate approaching collapse with
individual units avoiding or having
refused combat murdering their officers
drug ridden and dispirited we're not
near mutinous
that's an assessment in the armed forces
journal in 1971
from a colonel a full bird colonel
according to basker and strauss the most
serious symptom of the crisis and
discipline in vietnam was fragging real
or threatened assaults on officers and
high-ranking sergeants the practice got
its name from fragmentation grenade
which would be rolled into the area
where an officer or nco was sleeping
when it exploded no fingerprints could
be found
the target was often a leader who was
hated because he was incompetent in
leading men or excessively harsh in his
discipline or overly aggressive in
waging war
putting the lives of soldiers and
marines and at unnecessary risk just so
that he could gain glory and advance his
own career
in addition to thousands of threats that
were never carried out there were
confirmed reports of at least 800
fraggings
or attempted fragments in the army in
the marine corps that's a lot 800
with 86 men killed and an estimated 700
wounded from frankie yep it's like
confirmed yep that's confirmed reports
that's some some turmoil right there
but this was probably only the tip of
the iceberg according to
historian west
the true figure may never be known
many officers felt unsafe simply because
they were authority figures during his
second tour in vietnam
major colin powell later for star
general said he was living in a large
tent and i moved my cot every night
partly to thor viet cong informants who
might be tracking me but also because i
did not rule out attacks on our
authority from within the battalion
itself
coming from colin powell
captain thomas
cecile
who was stationed at com ron camero
camron bay in 1970 1971 was so worried
about attacks on his life that during
his last month in vietnam he slept in
the military intelligence bunker and
only his battalion commander knew where
he was at night
among marines in 1968 fragging was a
worse problem than in illegal drug use
according to a team of marine corps
historians who wrote that although the
number of fraggings was relatively small
the knowledge that fraggings occurred
often had a chilling effect on a
leader's willingness to enforce
discipline
and again you know when you're when your
attitude is you're going to impose
things on people
and you're going to enforce discipline
instead of lead
and listen
and corrupt collaborate to figure out
how to execute things
[Applause]
and i know someone said how are you
gonna get him do it well you gotta
listen to him
and i've actually done that i did that
my whole career
most fraggings occurred inside camps
while out in jungles and rice pad
patties a different method was used by
infantrymen who wanted to kill quote bad
officers according to robert nylen the
combat infantry officer quoted earlier
sometimes an errant bullet struck an
incompetent fool and made a firefight
problem solved
during the war army private
an army private named paul solo was
quoted as saying the army keeps a lot of
strange dudes off the street
the most common example of strange dudes
were known in the military as misfits
chronically maladapted soldiers who were
unable to fit in with other soldiers
because they were disturbingly different
from everyone else misfits wrote arthur
peter barnes tend to share a number of
common characteristics a large majority
are high school dropouts who are often
slow-witted loner types who are not
particularly attractive or likeable in
civilian life most of them have been
losers many times over in the military
this pattern is repeated
if misfits manage to slip through
pre-induction screening and they enter
basic training their ability their
inability to adapt becomes noticeable
and they are usually discharged
sometimes with a diagnosis of
personality disorder but during the
vietnam war misfits were kept because of
manpower shortages most of them were
poor learners or slow adjusters they
were unable to make friends and they
became targets of their superiors rage
and their peers resentment
malcolm miller jones a veteran who grew
up in new york city noted that group
cohesion was important for platoons in
training and in combat and a man who
failed to work in sync with his comrades
and failed to do his share of the chores
was often the recipient of a blanket
party in which a blanket was thrown over
the man and his platoon meets mates
beat him anonymously with their fist a
blanket party would cause some men to
shape out become cooperative
but it failed to reform others
i mentioned some of the success stories
here's another success story there's a
chief hospital corpsman don phelps
who was in charge of a sick bay a big
sick bay and he had an assistant
that he calls elmer here not his real
name who was not too bright quote not
too bright
phelps was ordered to take elmer
and he was immediately surprised by the
young man's solid performance and
eagerness to plead please elmer made the
sick base sparkle with cleanliness
phelps said i couldn't ask for a cleaner
sharper space if i had a crew of five
working for me because of elmer's mental
limitations phelps said he never gave
him any large amount of detailed work
but in the basic cleaning jobs that he
assigned elmer took extreme pride in
what he did accomplish he was very
polite developed a highly commendable
appearance
the story of elmer supports the argument
made by many educators and psychologists
that low aptitude individuals can be
productive in low stress non-dangerous
situations
gives another example of a of a
lieutenant that has to type letters of
condolences home and
and he says my best typist was a young
man who seemingly never should have been
drafted or recruited his mental acuity
was severely disabled however he was
diligent in his duties never distracted
and rarely made an error i wish i had
more like him
awol
amps absent without lead the major
illegality in the armed forces during
the vietnam war was absenteeism awol
which is absence of less than 30 days in
desertion 30 days or longer during the
entire period of the vietnam war says
bhaskar and strauss there were
approximately 1.5 million awol incidents
and 500 000 desertion incidents
at the peak of the war in 1968 an
american soldier was going a wall every
two minutes and deserting every six
minutes in 1970 alone wrote marine
colonel robert d heinel jr the army had
65 000 deserters or roughly the
equivalent of four infantry divisions
project 100k men were more likely to run
away than other soldiers
so a wall is less than 30 days and then
that's desertion after that yep and it
was absent without without leave leo
often their behavior stem from their
personality and family history there's
100k people that go that run away many
of the men grew up in poor families no
father present little or no education
lots of chaos and confusion
for some low iq men running away was a
common response to stress and harassment
they failed to stop and ponder the many
warnings they had heard throughout their
time in the military warnings of the
dire consequences of going awol or
deserting they were told that a wall or
desertion would cause them to receive a
less than honorable discharge which
would make it difficult to get a good
job unfortunately the concept of a
lifelong stigma was too abstract to have
any real meaning for them
the guy who had troubles usually had
less intelligence didn't think ahead
most of these kids weren't bad they were
just dumb
it's coming from uh it's coming from a
battalion commander
there's a a little um uprising
in the uh in the presidio presidio in
san francisco they had like a prison
there
october 11 1968 a prisoner named richard
rusty bunch
who's described by relatives as high iq
but severely depressed and suicidal
asked a guard if i run will you shoot me
he requested that the guard aim at his
head and then he skipped away he'd gone
30 feet when the guard killed him with a
12-gauge shotgun blast in his back
the killing sparked a peaceful sit-down
protest by 27 of the prisoners their
spokesman tried to read a list of their
grievances but the prison commander 25
year old captain called in 75 mps to
encircle the huddled men together and
order a hole to the process protest
when the men refused all 27 were seized
and charged with mutiny
the charge was later reduced to willful
obedience disobedience of lawful order
in the following months three men
escaped to canada two were found guilty
of lesser charges 22 were found guilty
with sentences ranging from 6 months to
16 years
but ultimately none of them actually had
to serve service
served more than one year
thanks to the unfavorable publicity the
army received that's the
you can influence what's going on that's
why i said when you stand up and say hey
this doesn't make sense here this is
what
no one agrees with this you can actually
gain support yeah yeah and again it kind
of goes back you know in a small way
actually maybe in a big way to the that
like marketing campaign idea for sure
where
yelp review yeah yeah all that's all in
play right so yeah the government or if
you need people to fight your war
you better have a good marketing
campaign
and it's either going to be an easier
sell or a harder sell whatever that's
hey that's on you you know you got to
sell it decisions you make yeah yeah
absolutely and if you have to if it's
hard to sell things you need to think
about what you're doing well it
shouldn't be hard to sell things bro
yeah
yeah would it does people on my team not
want to win yeah and if they don't want
to win then we're not aligned so we have
a real problem but most of the time we
want to win
and then yeah so and the shoe's kind of
on the other foot as well if it's like
hey government it's not selling me
they're trying to impose so hey let me
mark it to why you know
why we shouldn't we don't have to do
this you know and boom you get that
support you get an effective successful
marketing campaign
unless your marketing campaign gets
banned
then you can market against them banning
your campaign
yeah but yeah yeah that's a little
tricky these days that makes it hard for
sure
bad paper
bad paper is when you get um
less than honorable discharge
or other than when it was time for
project 100k men to leave the military
men of them received a heavy blow
slightly over half of them a hundred and
eighty thousand so there's only three
hundred sixty thousand of these people
a hundred and eighty thousand were were
separated with discharges under
conditions other than honorable a stigma
that made it hard to get good jobs
because many employers would not hire
veterans who failed to produce a
certificate of honorable discharge they
were often barred from veterans benefits
such as health care housing assistance
employment and counseling
some of them became chronically homeless
and troubled
although some bad paper vets have been
guilty of serious offenses most have
been accused of minor offenses related
to the stresses of military life and
combat a wall missing duty abusing
alcohol or drugs or taking back or
talking back to a superior
there was a cruel irony in the less than
honorable discharges millions of men who
beat the draft legally by going to
college or getting braces etc suffered
nothing in fact they held an advantage
over men who served they got the first
crack at jobs compiled and compiled
seniority and experience even the draft
dodgers who fled to canada and sweden
got amnesty from presidents ford and
carter
but not mcnamara's bad paper vets
unlike the articulate politically astute
war resistors they had no one to lobby
for them
and then he talks about one guy that uh
bill daniel of nashville who'd been an
army recruiter in 1967.
when he was interviewed 35 years later
he was still bitter about the
approximately hundred mcnamara's morons
he had personally recruited in the slums
of cleveland ohio during the war it
didn't sit it didn't really sit too good
with me he said but when you are told to
do what to do in the military you know
what you you do what you were told to do
they never should have been in the
military many of the low aptitude men
that he and his fellow recruiters signed
up were either killed in combat when
they left the or when they left the army
they were departed with less than
honorable discharges for such offenses
as going awol insubordination
or bedwetting
you take a man who can't read or write
he said he never knew about deferments
he comes from the ghetto and he may not
want to take orders and you send him to
the
by the most expedient means necessary
into combat
that's only going to lead to failure
fast forward a little bit several
veterans counselors in the 1980s told me
of some similar experiences with low via
low iq vietnam veterans when review
boards were asked to change a discharge
from undesirable to general the
uniformed officers who were
compassionate toward project hundred k
men would approve the change
so we got people trying to get these
bad discharges
changed
and the military uniformed officers like
yeah we need to give these guys a break
but they would be overruled by civilian
superiors who regarded men who had gone
awol as slackers who deserve no mercies
in an absurd turn of events some of
these civilians who viewed themselves as
upholding military tradition had been
draft avoiders during the vietnam war
it was infuriating to see these
officials
kick the very men who had served in
their stead
so here is the
the verdict kind of puts out some word
on mcnamara's
plan
at the dawn of project 100k robert
mcnamara boasted that the program would
quote salvage the poverty poverty scar
youth of our society and at the rate of
a hundred thousand men each year
first for two years of military service
and then for a lifetime of product
productive activity in civilian society
end quote
despite the soaring optimism
project 100k became known as mcnamara's
folly
it was a failure
bringing more suffering than redemption
though some
project 100k men did well in the service
passing basic training going on to
productive military assignments
large numbers of them had trouble coping
with the demands of military life they
were often hazed and ridiculed and
demeaned it was ironic that mcnamara in
one of his speeches extolling project
100k
said i have directed that these men
shall never be singled out or
stigmatized in any manner
end quote
and then he puts somehow his order never
worked its way down to company level
some veterans of project 100k were
psychologically devastated by the war dr
john wilson a psychologist at cleveland
state university who spent several years
studying vietnam veterans emotional
problems estimated that thousands of
project 100k men who had served in
southeast asia were so severely messed
up that they couldn't function in
society when i say severely messed up i
mean they can't hold jobs raise families
and cope with day-to-day living
mcnamara had predicted that life after
they returned to civilian
world project 100k men would have an
earning capacity quote two to three
times that it would have been had there
been no such program
after the war however
a follow-up study on project 100k men
showed that in late 19 in that in the
1986 to 1987 labor market
they were either no better off or
actually worse off than non-veterans of
similar aptitude
so much for
mcnamara's rosy prediction in 2014 when
many vietnam veterans were entering
their retirement years a study funded by
the department of veterans affairs
estimated that
more than 283 000 veterans still
suffered from post-traumatic stress
disorder which was characterized by
disabling flashbacks hyperarousal and
sleep problems
the key the study's key takeaway is that
for some ptsd is not going away said
william schleger
a lead scientist on the study
it is chronic and prolonged for veterans
with ptsd the war is not over
the study found that low iq veterans
were more likely to suffer from ptsd
than high iq vets
project 100k and mcnamara's other
failures in the war wrecked his
reputation
at first admired for his intelligence
and analytical prowess author thomas
schticht wrote
mcnamara later became one of the most
hated men in america by the officers and
enlisted personnel he had led
one officer
angry over the abuse of mentally limited
men in the armed forces even confronted
mcnamara in public
at a conference in washington d.c as
mcnamara touted the virtues of project
100k an army psychologist who was
treating psychologically afflicted
affected afflicted vietnam veterans at
walter reed army medical center stood up
and spoke out
although mcnamara was a me although a
mere captain
dr walter p
nake
k-n-a-k-e told mcnamara what you're
doing is wrong
and by the way dr walter p nake
i looked him up
he's alive if he wants to come on the
podcast he's invited
did mcnamara ever express regret over
project hundred thousand biographer
deborah shapley says that to the very
end he refused to apologize or admit
error
mcnamara wanted to believe the project
100k was a universally successful
program but his self-congratulation was
at odds with the verdict of most
scholars and other observers
appy said project 100k was instituted
with high-minded rhetoric about offering
the poor an opportunity to serve its
result however was to send many poor
terribly confused and woefully
undereducated boys to risk death in
vietnam annie p baker history professor
at wheaton college
said project 100k or mcnamara's morons
as the cruel joke went was a disaster
benefiting neither the men nor the armed
forces
jacob hellebrand
of georgetown university said mcnamara's
experiment in social engineering had the
most awful results including ridicule
and training camps and death in vietnam
samuel f yeat
a professor at howard university said
that instead of preparing impoverished
young men with skills for a better life
project 100k was little more than
express vehicle to vietnam denouncing
mcnamara for his intellectual arrogance
and duplicity myra mcpherson author of
the vietnam classic long time passing
called project hundred thousand a
shameful brainchild and one of the most
heinous acts as the chief as
one of his most heinous acts as chief
architect of the war
on the last day of 1971
project 100k was officially ended and in
july of 1973 the draft was replaced by
the all-volunteer force
passing the afqt was raised from the
10th percentile iq of 72 to the old
standard of the 31st percent percentile
iq of 92.
so they did they shut it down
but he goes to point on that this kind
of thing still happens he says in 1976
charlie wilson congressman from texas
testified uh at a hearing about the
death of one of his constituents lynn
mchugh mcclure
who was a 20 year old young man from
lufkin texas who had a history of
non-success who was mentally [__]
who weighed 115 pounds somehow got into
the marine corps and was severely beaten
during basic training and died as a
result of those injuries without
regaining
consciousness in tulsa oklahoma 1976 25
year old man walked out of a state
mental institution where he'd lived for
14 years and wandered into an army
recruiting station he had been diagnosed
as having what today is called down
syndrome
was labeled severely [__] [__]
when he entered the recruiting station
he was promptly enlisted by a sergeant
who
a later investigative
investigation revealed faked his test
scores he was sent to fort ord
california for basic training soon
deserted came back to tulsa
arrested
put in the fort sill stockade to face
court martial psychiatrist examined him
and found he had the mental capacity of
a nine-year-old
even up to today in the drawn out wars
in iraq and afghanistan fast forward a
little bit beginning in 2001 the u.s did
not bring back the draft but there were
many parallels to vietnam as the
military accepted low-performing
recruits because it was desperate for
more and more soldiers for combat
an army private named
david dietrich of petrie perry county
pennsylvania was subject of a newsweek
article entitled he never should have
gone to iraq
before and during his army time he was
considered slow in his thinking he had
trouble retaining information in basic
training he couldn't hit targets on the
rifle range even though he was given
extra training one superior campaign to
have dietrich sent home on grounds that
he would pose a danger to himself and
others if he was sent to iraq but the
request was rebuffed by hires up
as with vietnam there was a big push to
get troops in the combat zone soon after
he arrived in iraq he was assigned to
act as a scout in an abandoned building
where he was supposed to watch from an
open window
a few minutes after starting his duty
in the window he was shot dead
that was in december 2006 in ramadi
right after we left
2007 nine marine corps recruiters
worked in the houston area were punished
for using stand-ins to take mental tests
at the
houston induction center for 15 marginal
prospects who might not have passed the
tests on their own the fraud was caught
by an official who noticed the
signatures of the test takers didn't
match those on the enlistment forms
no one knew how long the fraudulent test
taking had been going on
yeah that's 2007 by the way
from 2004 to 2007 four major branches of
the armed forces granted 125 000 moral
waivers to override the rule against
accepting people with criminal criminal
records stephen green stephen green
20 an angry misfit and high school
dropout from midland texas who had
racked up jail time for drug and alcohol
offenses before he joined the army with
a moral waiver
in 2006 green and four other soldiers in
iraq drank alcohol changed into black
clothes and then raided the home of a
husband and wife and their two daughters
green killed the parents and the younger
daughter then he and a second soldier
raped the 14 year old daughter shot her
sent fire to her body to just body to
try to destroy the evidence
he's convicted of rape and murder and
sentenced to life in prison
2014 he committed suicide by hanging him
but why is that guy in the military
here's the closer of this book
one of the lessons of mcnamara's project
100k is that the low aptitude
individuals should never be used in war
zone or in a dangerous rear echelon
areas putting their lives at risk is
cruel and immoral and on sheer practical
level it degrades the effectiveness of
war efforts the least intelligent among
us should never be viewed as expendable
units of manpowers
but as our fellow sojourners on this
fragile earth deserving respect and
compassion and gratitude for the
contributions they make to our families
in our society
while vowing to never again induct
people with intellectual disabilities
americans should also heed warnings by
military leaders that it is a mistake to
take inductees who have criminal
backgrounds medical defects social
maladjustment and psychiatric disorders
the armed forces need and deserve the
best and the brightest
one of the wisest quotations that i
recorded earlier in this book comes from
lieutenant colonel john
leslie john shellhace a world war ii
veteran who helped create project 100k
but who was strongly opposed to sending
the men into combat
quote
wars are not won by using marginal
manpower as cannon fodder
but rather by risking
and sometimes losing
the flower of a nation's youth
so
there you have it
not not exactly an uplifting
book
definitely worth buying definitely worth
reading but it's not gonna
not gonna make you feel any better about
things
and then so the the what what why read
it what do we take away from it why are
we talking about on this podcast because
what can we learn from it
that's the that's the thing what can we
learn from it and i think one of the big
things we can learn from it
is
you have to push back you have to
question you have to question authority
authority is not always right just
because someone is in a position of
authority doesn't mean they're right
and in fact
an indicator of them not being right is
when they impose things on you
that's an indicator that they're not
right if you have to impose something on
someone it's an indication that you're
what you're doing is not right and if
you're having something imposed on you
that's an indication that whoever's
imposing on you is not right
or at least they're not confirmed
because
if i have to impose something on you why
why
if i can't explain to you how this is
going to help you help your family help
your community help your country if i
can't explain that to you
and the only way i can get you to do
something is by imposing on you it's if
there's a good chance it's wrong
so
again back to my earlier
uh emotional reaction to the draft
dodgers right but it's i understand it
once i took a step back
you you you understand don't look
i understand it
does it still
make me angry that there's people that
look what can you imagine watching your
again i'm gonna get emotional but you
watch
your neighbor go off to war while you
stay at home yeah like there's some
there's something wrong with that
picture so from that level
i i don't
i can't understand it can't agree with
it when you start looking at it from a
level of oh this is being imposed on the
country
and the leadership can't explain why
it's happening
and they're trying to sell it to us and
they can't even sell it to us they can't
so they have to impose
so we have a moral responsibility to
question authority
to question the government
to figure out what it is we're actually
doing
and
you know you take a guy like mcnamara i
could probably we should probably do a
huge podcast about mcnamara at some
point um
because he all the things that i talk
about for bad leadership he knocks a
bunch of them out of the park
uh he he doesn't understand people he
only listens to statistics there's a
there's a i know you like biases
echo charles yes the mcnamara fallacy
you ever heard of that the mcnamara bias
that's when you just go off of
statistics you just look at the numbers
and you make a decision based
on your quantitative observations and
that's it based on the metrics hey the
metrics say this that's what we're doing
it's a fallacy doesn't account for
emotions doesn't account for
personalities doesn't account for the
human side of things and it doesn't work
so we can learn about leadership by
reading this book
and we can learn
clearly that we also have a moral
obligation to protect people that are
weak protect people that are
mentally and physically disabled
and we need to be empathetic to other
people to understand what they're where
they're coming from like you read about
some of those leaders in this book where
you know the platoon commander took the
the the mcnamara 100k
soldier took him under his wing protect
him took care of him
and there's a bunch of examples in there
like that
don't put don't put people into
positions that they cannot handle
and i'm not talking about don't push
people but don't put them into
situations especially if they're gonna
be hazardous to them where they can get
hurt or killed if they haven't been
trained if they're not capable of doing
that thing
certainly don't put them in danger
what does that mean it means be a good
freaking human being that's what it
means
be a good person
that's what i learned
yeah did they um i mean when they kind
of laid that out i
like all this program is going to have
this this this benefit on these people
who otherwise wouldn't have these
benefits they're going to be trained
they're going to be more capable and all
this stuff or whatever and it's like
you kind of wondered did they
believe that because if you do like us
what's the opposite of a straw man i
think it's called i don't know it's an
iron man i don't know whatever him still
man steel man yeah
so the steel man argument for that is
kind of like yeah like there are success
stories and and those success stories
kind of play out exactly how they're
purporting you know this is gonna apply
to everyone
but
like i said like it's not a vacuum and
it's not you know people are different
and when you kind of take it as a whole
the reality sets in where it's like nah
man this is going to leave people
straight up
dead confused freaking
like
worse off you know just because all of
the the
unintended consequences
um
but you wonder like i wonder if that was
on purpose that they're kind of like oh
yeah maybe all these other consequences
or did they really kind of think that
yeah that's
you could see that
mcnamara is surrounded by
yes men
so here's the thing i might believe
something
but i'm surrounded by people that be
like hey john that might not be the best
idea and i'll even say that myself wait
am i real are we really going to take a
a kid from some rural area that's got a
fourth grade education that's got an iq
of 60 and we're gonna turn their lives
around or take some kid from the inner
city ghetto
and all of a sudden oh the inner city
ghetto kid with an iq of 64 is going to
be like oh great i'm looking forward to
following orders and peeling potatoes in
the u.s army like like we have we impose
we overlay our
thoughts on the people that we have no
idea what they're like yeah and that's
the point right there where you have no
idea yeah you're over here oh yeah this
guy's gonna be more capable like well
how do you know like even i'm not saying
no one's gonna but then you're you're
accounting for like so many people so
many different types of people by the
way
and you're assigning one
success you're a solution you're also
assigning your values and your
perspective to a bunch of other people
yeah yeah that's that's the worst part
you're assigning your values and your
perspective to a bunch of other people
which is a freaking massive mistake
well of course they're going to get on
board
of course of course they're going to get
on board yeah it doesn't happen you know
when you see that you see that with your
kids you'll be like it's like
so many kids would have killed for the
opportunity to do this yeah yeah yeah
you know you're like
you're imposing your
your values and your perspective on
other people and it doesn't work it
doesn't work i'm sure mcnamara's like
hey this is you know
johnny from wherever this rural area in
the middle of nowhere whose main goal in
life is to freaking work at the service
station
because he likes cars yeah
that's a good example that's a good
point with the kids right so i remember
my brother was
talking to my daughter um and he was
like doing some math problem you know on
the thing oh yeah and he's like all into
it you know and then she's until she was
like kind of bored with it and she's
like oh like let's do something else or
whatever he's like no no no math is fun
and then like
me and my wife are looking at each other
like what the hell is this guy who does
he think he's talking to you know
eight-year-old
girl he's gonna be like yeah yep and
there's a small population of the world
that think it's fun yeah maybe yeah one
of them
and he's and jay charles not gonna be
able to impose his perspective no no on
her oh yeah
so that's another good thing to be very
careful of that mcnamara can teach us
because in his mind everyone's just
thinking the way he's thinking and he's
surrounded by a bunch of yes men that
are saying yeah of course little johnny
in
the rural area or this kid down in the
ghetto johnny in the ghetto is going to
be just down for the cause yeah they're
going to be capable what a great
opportunity right right great
opportunity
oh you're gonna send me that freaking
army boot camp
that sounds like a great opportunity
thank you so much for this educational
opportunity yeah
and thinking he's all benevolent
it's a good question that you posed did
they actually believe that or was that
just
propaganda that's a good question
i get my guess is they believed it
yeah especially in the beginning but the
thing is the army got the uniform army
people saying dude no bad call not gonna
work then again think about it because
you could see like one of these people
especially if you're used to just like
handling people on that with that kind
of numbers you know we need a thousand
guys here we need ten thousand guys like
who are we gonna put like you're not
dealing with he actual human beings
anymore in your head you're like
get the guys who don't have nothing to
live for throw them in there yeah you
know we'll give an opportunity yeah sure
they should be happy they should be
thankful when when i started teaching
jiu jitsu to like team guys
the funny thing is i thought that every
i thought that i thought i would have a
a a rate of acceptance and wanting to
train of 100 percent i bet everybody hey
when i when i show this to you you're
gonna 100 i'm gonna
well how am i gonna do this how am i
gonna train all these guys all the time
they're just gonna want to train or i'm
gonna have to do in the morning i have
to do it at night we training all the
time i imposed my perspective on
everybody
my values on it
and the reality is i would get probably
out of every
20 people
20 people i would introduce to jiu jitsu
1 out of 20 would be into it
see and even that kinda maybe this is my
bias but that to me seems like that's a
reasonable expectation reasonable that's
how wrong you think that's how wrong i
am and i am and i am an actual seal
yeah
it's not like i'm talking about some
other group of people this is this is
i'm a seal i've been a seal for 10 years
at this point and i'm thinking oh well
of course anyone that i show this to is
going to be bought and we're going to
build a train all the time you know
seals you know how they think yeah for
sure
so
man yeah i was wrong i'm wrong and
that's one of those things it's saying
that that ufc tool when i went to
virginia and watched the ufc it's the
same thing i realized i'm wrong that's
another thing teaching guys jiu jitsu
i'm wrong not everyone's into it not
everyone thinks like i think
some some people think way better than
me some people think different than me
but i cannot overlay my perspective on
people and neither can you so don't do
it watch out if you're doing that
it's a bias i wonder what that bias is
called when i overlay my perspective on
you
i think everyone thinks the way i think
they don't in fact almost no one thinks
the way you think and that's a fun thing
team guys do think alike there's a whole
lot of group thing going on
you know everyone likes certain stuff
there's a huge overlap for the amount of
people that are in the seals the venn
diagram of like interest and what we
think is funny and what we think is cool
it's a big overlap and i'll tell you
what in the 90s it was an even bigger
overlap because there was a much less
culture that you were exposed to because
you didn't have the internet oh yeah so
you you know if you were going to get
exposed to music it was going to be from
some other team guy that was going to
check this band out alice in chains okay
cool let me check it out there was no
one introducing you to some random band
from ohio that you never heard of
whereas now you can just
that'll just pop up on your stream
so in the 90s it was a much more
unified group
and that's why each team had its own
little personality
and each platoon inside the team had its
own little personality now
the world
is more
there's so many more fractions that you
can get into
which when you think of from a global
perspective is bringing people together
because now everyone
everyone listens to more music everyone
sees a bunch of movies
when i grew up
music was a thing a record cost freaking
you know 7.99 which was a lot of money
sure
so
you didn't buy a bunch of records you
didn't get to listen to a bunch of
different music not like now what
you can listen to anything you want you
hear of a band for one split second you
can get their whole catalog for nothing
like think about it remember even like
movies
like you'd have to go buy
the tape yeah and everyone in 1985
everyone saw the movie
because there was only nine movies yeah
everyone saw yeah it's true everyone
heard the song yeah everyone knew that
album because everyone had that album
that was the only album there was to get
1984 by van halen every single person i
knew had that album oh yeah in 1984.
every that's crazy right every single
person knew that i don't know any hit
songs right now i don't know any of them
i don't even know what a hit is there
such a thing anymore
i don't know but i'm listening to music
yeah i'm listening to i'm even listening
to newer music that's coming out but i'm
not listening to what everyone else is
listening to
so we have a less unified situation but
it that makes it even harder for me to
impose my little ideas on you and and
and transfer my values onto you it
doesn't work yeah
that's true all right well
[Music]
we want to help people you know we
definitely want to help people out and
let's talk about some things that might
be able to help people out
yeah we here
are doing a few things to help people
because we are on this path and if we're
not we're trying to be most of us
i'm not just going to impose my i'm not
just going to assume that's not what i'm
going to do so here's the deal what are
what is it that people may need in the
world right now i can tell you one thing
that people need from time to time
sometimes you need a little extra
let's call it energy
energy helps for sure because the energy
will help you to get through maybe you
gotta work to do what you got to work
out to do maybe you got the jiu jitsu to
do maybe you want to stretch maybe you
want to get up this is stuff we got to
do maybe you got to just focus on
getting done with some work so you can
go work out yep so sometimes you need
some energy yes we made something we
made some energy
releasing projects that will release an
energy into your brain and body yes so
if you're if you're into energy drinks
or
you think you might benefit again this
is me just not imposing my wait a second
even if you're not into energy drinks
because you might not be there's a good
chance i wasn't in energy drinks oh yeah
especially if it's for a reason because
the reason i wasn't in energy drinks is
because they were made of poison yes and
i wasn't going to put poison into my
body
despite the fact that it might give me a
short-term gain of like a little bit of
hype
then i have a long crash i have health
issues i have a whole deal yep so we're
not doing that nope we got good news we
got a new era of energy drinks
uh jaco discipline go energy drink all
healthy
no sugar
it's sweet still
got the monk fruit we've got the monk
fruit see
so good stuff no artificial stuff in
there none all natural no preservatives
even so this is a healthy energy drink
yeah
good uh good front side good backside
boom good to go you'll be healthy short
term strategic and tactical
tactical win strategic boom so yes you
are correct you cannot beat into energy
drinks per se and still be into this and
it's helpful on this path that we're on
so we're helpful so we are good to go so
check it out yes check those out
you know try one see which flavor is
your your favorite we got powder too by
the way yeah you can get a powdered form
of that you can get a powdered
discipline go pre-workout yeah
oh yeah and that that's another good one
where the traditional pre-workout i can
see why people are not into that here's
the thing i'll even i'll admit it i was
kind of i got off home for various
reasons for kind of the reason we're
talking about where it's like i know the
benefits of a traditional pre-workout
but you got to e-pay a price with those
you know there's all stuff in them and
all this stuff and you kind of get
there's like this itchy feeling
that you get on your face and all this
stuff from a pre-workout
it is weird but
when it comes with that that boost or
whatever you kind of accept it then you
kind of embrace it then it's kind of
like yeah you know it's working kind of
a thing but after a while you're like i
don't know if i should be taking this
stuff through
so i kind of stopped but this one's not
like that so this pre-workout
discipline go pre-workout doesn't give
you all that weird jittery all that
weird downside the itchy face even
though some of us might still like it
even though that's not very beneficial
in a workout you're just working out
with itchy face working out without with
not a itchy face that's the only
difference um as far as the itchy face
goes but
still gives you
the good workout the vasodilation that
we look for
really good so
you got that you got the pills by the
way if you need to take that quick
hitter and look then you're gonna go
blast a workout brush
yes i think that's what you need
some protein yeah you need some protein
to recover i have some recovery i have
an announcement to make to the world all
right
um
you know elvis presley i guess the last
thing that he ate before he died was a
peanut butter banana sandwich oh okay
cool now this is the king of rock and
roll you know what i'm saying this guy
is the king of rock and roll we have to
we have to
hold his opinions
at some level of reverence because he is
the king of rock and roll
now unfortunately for him he wasn't
healthy right
the you know things got the best of him
maybe the peanut butter he had fried
peanut butter and banana sandwiches
right oh the sandwich was fried yeah
okay upside taste real good right
downside
just
off
there's a lot of downsides yes sir
there's a lot of downside so
we can we can actually have upside
upside you want that taste take get some
peanut butter milk
get some banana cream milk put one scoop
of each and you got yourself a little
treat
you got yourself a little elvis treat
i'll tell you if you want to boost that
one which that's a good move right there
and i'm literally going to try that so
good so you get one scoop banana banana
cream bomber to be specific one scoop
peanut butter chocolate
then you put
half a cup chocolate milk
damn the rest regular milk or almond
milk whatever you like
and then one frozen banana
see i'm saying oh and one scoop peanut
butter but this is untested what you're
talking about this is my hypothesis
before you do that try what i just said
yeah
mix your fluid of choice almond milk
coconut milk what what what's the other
one oat milk i guess hell yeah or dairy
milk or regular milk
just try one in one and tell me what you
think before you go crazy before you're
out there getting chocolate milk down
the store or getting tulsi's banana out
the freezer
i'm an advocate of
getting cr because it's one of those
things where you have like the perfect
base because you don't need anything
additional you don't need it's perfect
as far as like just enhancement oh is
that a video that you make
yeah something like that yeah exactly
so yes perfect best tasting protein that
there is
really
boom that that's going to help you out
get yourself some more get yourself some
mobility and joint health right that's
where we got the joint warfare the krill
oil yeah go go read the reviews of of
either one of those two let's see what's
up yeah it's true yeah also immunity oh
yeah you want that immunity you do yeah
we yes we do want the immunity so
immunity and joints by the way is one of
those things where men until you get
compromised it gets compromised we might
not we might not think about it all the
time but boom you got to stay ahead of
that train right there yeah so yes
vitamin d3 and it's a a product
substance um capsules called cold war
mm-hmm oh man those will keep you out of
a jam first you're out of the gym also
you've got kids get some more of your
kid milk for those kids we don't want to
poison our children no seems obvious
you wouldn't even think you'd need to
say that and yet go to the store and
look at what people are buying to feed
their children
they're going to feed their children
poison don't do that get them some
warrior kid moka by the way they're
super stoked
only product and this is the most
unified product where the parents want
it as much as the kids the parent the
kids want it as much as the parents want
them to have it
because your kids like oh i want my kid
to be strong yeah and healthy cool and
the kid's like i want something that
tastes awesome cool we're a good mok you
might be
you probably are kind of past this
you've probably been out of this game
for a while but
getting little kids to like
eat their dinner right or either
whatever and then the kid being like a
picky eater or whatever right
so that's like a challenge i'm a big
eater
for years
but that can be a challenge with the
kids you just want to get them fed into
bed you don't want to starve your kids
and then you know they're you're not
going to force you so it becomes a thing
right so sometimes the easy path right
is to be like you know what let me just
give them something that tastes good and
get this food down man you know he's not
starving whatever she's not starving
but here's the thing so in that battle
because that can be a battle i'm not
saying for everybody but that that's a
common battle that i hear about this is
one of those
just one of those solutions or it's like
yup they're not going to protest they're
going to love that one and then boom
they get their protein they get their
nutrients perfect everything we're
talking about you can get it at
jockofield.com you can also get some tea
if you need some tea some chocolate tea
there
jackalfield.com if you subscribe to any
of these things you get free shipping
that way we can compete
with the global
corporations that are just shipping
stuff to you for for nothing
but they're they're getting theirs
i mean they're getting theirs uh so if
you want to if you want to do that
jackalful.com subscribe you get free
shipping also you can get the drinks out
wawa
where
what whoa what and the vitamin shop you
can get all the products at the vitamin
shoppe so go check those out
so there you go also origin usa this is
where you can get your american-made
jeans boots
some wallets on there a bunch of good
stuff jiu-jitsu stuff geez no here's the
thing they're not just like regular
freaking
like
generic-ish stuff you know do you know
neil black belt neil
here
neal yeah anyways i was rolling with him
and i he's he trains mma and so you
probably he trains mma during the day
that's probably why you don't know him
because you don't train mma during the
day
but he happened to throw gea on the
other day and we were rolling and uh
he like grabbed my key
and then he was all like hey what is
this he started caring he started
caressing me like stop rolling to ask me
about i go yeah bro oh yeah this is the
this is called the rift that makes
complete sense to me and that's how all
of it is too by the way so i have
two pairs of delta 68 genes i have the
factory genes
even when you put those on you're like
oh there's a little bit more to these
just from like a
physical
presence present standpoint yes sir
so yes they you know they they're the
origin usa.com is where you can get this
stuff um but
this there's
okay american-made yes we'll get to that
but a lot goes into this from the
beginning to the end and when you put it
on you can tell and you can also tell
that it's made in america yes sir you
can tell it's made in america when you
see
people
bringing back
machines from overseas which we
literally brought back machines from
overseas to start making stuff back here
and make more stuff back into america i
mean come on are you serious right now
yeah we're serious why
we want to st we want to help people we
want to help our communities we want to
help our country how do you do that go
get something from originusa.com
help everybody you know
and
be super comfortable
oh yeah that's good so i feel like i
feel like my um
wardrobe
is essentially taken over by origin
stuff yeah i've literally seen one of my
old favorite sweat or sweater hoodies
whatever
literally sitting in front of me and i
spent 30 minutes looking for the origin
one yeah there you go yeah you want that
one yep fully original dot com also
jacqueline's a store it's going to
represent while you're on this path you
want to represent discipline equals
freedom
you want a shirt a hat a hoodie
that's where you can get it so yes
dockstore.com uh there's uh some new
stuff on there there's always new stuff
on there the jiu jitsu section the jiu
jitsu section is coming along how many
shirts are in the jiu jitsu section we
have
one there there's one it's not really a
section yet well
we're completely um what do you call it
they're in transit to be on by the time
this comes out
tomorrow might be on there maybe maybe
not i don't know either way all these
new stuff on there new stuff uh speaking
of new stuff short locker
new shirt every month it's a
subscription scenario you get a new
shirt every month if you don't know
about this it uh the designs are a
little bit different but they're very
appropriate very good now you finally
found what you're gonna say you used to
say like well they're kind of now you're
saying appropriate i like it good space
to be because that is the most accurate
as of right now i would i would agree
with you they are appropriate all of
them did you see uh now that you didn't
see there's the the february one which
is it's not february yet so you gotta
you gotta wait for that i think you
might
you might appreciate that one okay check
uh
speaking of subscriptions subscribe to
this podcast wherever you subscribe to
podcast leave a review so that i can
make fun of echo charles for what you
say about him sure
we also have the unraveling podcast with
daryl cooper grounded podcast which
dean's been hitting me up once to get
back
to the grounded game so we'll probably
make that happen warrior kid podcast
you can also join us on the underground
jockowunderground.com
look
were we are we
are we nervous
about people getting canceled and banned
and all this other
stuff i'm not nervous i don't stay up at
night thinking about it but is it smart
to just sit around and not pay attention
no it's not you can see people
literally getting
removed from platforms right now
they removed
joe rogan had a guest on who's a harvey
harvard doctor
and they didn't like what he said they
removed it from youtube which is which
seems kind of crazy right yeah very i
don't know what you know what is he
saying that needs to be removed so no
one can hear it
yeah a harvard
medical doctor
does that and it's just a little clip
you know a little clip
oh we're going to remove that
so look
am i staying awake
not staying awake but am i paying
attention yes i am do we need to have a
contingency plan yes we do
contingency plan jackonground.com
if you
want to help us with that platform you
can go to jackondeground.com you
subscribe it costs 8 18 cents a month
then if anything ever happens this
platform will be there
we'll be there we'll do what we got to
do i don't think it's going to happen
but that way we don't have to take on a
bunch of sponsors that say hey you
couldn't talk about that
we don't want you to talk about that you
said bad things about mcnamara
yeah right
you said bad things about dick cheney
well who's gonna what are they gonna say
you said bad things about bill clinton
he's a draft dodger and mitt romney
okay well maybe we'll just get taken
down no not on the underground
underground's ours
so if you can't afford 8 18 cents a
month we still would
and you still want to be in the game
cool email assistance at
jockwanderground.com we'll take care of
you
also we have a youtube channel speaking
of adding bananas and chocolate milk to
mulk sure
usually unnecessary some people might
want to those kind of enhancements that
i go charles does with some of his
videos sure
explosions smoke
fire
music i'm making a video with
explosions more gunfire than anything
small explosions
nonetheless that's just a heads up for
you bro so there you go you subscribe to
that also origin usa has a has a if you
don't know what's happening in america
with american manufacturing go to origin
usa
subscribe to their youtube channel as
well
we have psychological warfare
what's that all about it's an album so
an album me and jocko jocko and i made
to facilitate my moments of weakness and
i got a bunch had a bunch
jaco talking me through weakness free
now are you weakness-free well
let's
face it
we're never really weak no one's never
always
if you ever had a thought of man i wish
i wish i had jocko kind of in my ear
just to kind of let me know every once
in a while give me a little
psychological spot when i come across
these moments that's exactly what this
is so yeah psychological warfare get it
where you can get any mp3s and boom
joshua got you speaking of reminders of
staying on the path flipsidecampus.com
dakota meyer
one of my favorite dudes in the world
it's awesome when your heroes are your
friends dakota meyer's got a company
called flipsidecampus.com where he's
making cool stuff to hang on your wall
check that out
we also have some books final spin
read it explore your brain a little bit
see where it ends up
take a little emotional roller coaster
of a ride
also leadership strategy and tactics
field manual to code the evaluation the
protocols displace freedom field manual
way the warrior kid one two three and
four get that book for the freaking kids
you know please
mikey and the dragons about face by
hackworth i wrote the forward to the new
version extreme ownership and the
dichotomy of leadership
also have echelon front which is a
leadership consultancy leadership is the
solution to your problems
so if you want to solve your problems in
your organization go to echelonfront.com
that's where you can get details for all
the
training that we offer including the
muster field training exercises
battlefield next musters dallas texas
march 24th and 25th we also also have
online training extreme ownership
academy
if you want to take ownership of your
life
if you want to learn the pragmatic
methods to take ownership of your life
you want to learn how to interact with
other people you want to learn how to
settle down problem situations you want
to learn how to detach and not get
emotional when you shouldn't get
emotional
you want to learn how to lead and you
want to learn how to follow and you want
to learn how to move forward in your
life
go to extreme ownership.com that's what
we're teaching there
i'm on there all the time live you want
to ask me a question come ask me a
question there
come and ask me a question there
extremeownership.com if you want to help
service members active and retired your
families
gold star families
check out mark lee's mom mama lee she's
got a charity organization if you want
to donate or you want to get involved go
to america's mightywarriors.org
and if you want more of my doom-filled
diatribes
or you need more of echo's distracting
dialogue
you can find us on the interwebs
on the gram on facebook on twitter on
getter
get it
echoes out equatrols i am at
jackal willink
and thanks to all the military members
in uniform right now doing what needs to
be done to protect our freedom and our
way of life
the same goes to police law enforcement
firefighters paramedics emts dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
secret service and all first responders
out there thank you for protecting our
way of life here at home
and everyone else out there
remember
to make yourself as capable as possible
strong
fast
smart
and then remember that there are people
who are not as capable as you are not
because they're lazy or lackadaisical or
lack worth at work ethic
but they simply do not have the capacity
and then do your best
to help those people out
which is part of being a good person
and will make their world
and thereby our world
just a little bit better
thanks for listening and until next time
this is echo and jocko